oh
okay well
welcome
um
really pleased to have you here my name
is susan stokes i am the director of the
council on latin american iberian
studies at yale um we are a co-sponsor
of this event and we're very pleased to
be able to to hold it
i just wanted to say a few words of
gratitude to
the macmillan center at yale which has
generously funded our work and and this
conference
thanks to the law school for this
wonderful venue
thank you very much to daniel juarez who
is our
our staff
coordinator at kleis and who is tireless
and
and carries off on unbelievable numbers
of events and and uh and and um just
does a great job um
thank you as well um to the main kind of
instigators of this event stuart
schwartz uh professor of in our history
department
and um
and uh moria maria jordan arroyo
maria is going to i'm going to turn
things over to her in a minute she's
going to give introduction so my job is
to introduce the introducer
many of you know her she is a senior
lecturer in yale's department of spanish
and portuguese and a lecturer in the
department of history here at yale
she's a former associate master i think
we now call them heads of ezra styles
college which is a residential college
here at yale and she doesn't have any
gray hairs but if she did it would be
because of her years at ezra styles
maria was educated at the university of
puerto rico and has a master's and phd
degrees from the university of minnesota
although her research and publication
has concentrated on the golden a golden
age spain she's maintained a very deep
and uh and profound interest in her
native puerto rico um the culture
politics and social conditions of of
puerto rico
and she's been absolutely instrumental
in planning this event and so i'm going
to turn things over to her thank you
[Applause]
okay
ready
okay
as a puerto rican and
a member of the yale faculty i want to
welcome everyone and especially our
guests from puerto rico
this event was conceived as a way to
establish a dialogue with scholars and
professionals of different fields to
help us understand the present economic
crisis of puerto rico the context that
generated it
and the role of the fiscal oversight
board
created and imposed by the government of
the united states under the law
called so-called promesa this entity has
complete powers over the fiscal and
economic affairs of the island
and its
and its proposed drastic authority
fiscal measures have dramatically
unveiled the continuing colonial status
of puerto rico
our speakers will examine the social
legal
and political repercussions of this
imposition
and the negative effects that the
implementation of these measures will
have on the population
hopefully our discussions will move us
to speculate about the future destiny of
the puerto ricans at a moment that many
of us perceive as a crucial
moment in the history of our country
given the unrest
dislocation discomfort and in many cases
tragedy created by these plants
it is my hope
and my sincere desire that this dialogue
will not end here and will carry far
beyond these walls
i will also like to express my thanks to
the macmillan center to the center for
the latino american studies and to the
yale law school for their joint
sponsorship in this roundtable
especially to susan stocks to danielle
juarez to trisha connelly marilyn weeks
and my stepson lee schwartz who designed
the poster of the vent
thank you so much
and now i'm gonna briefly
do the introduction of the moderator of
the panel
is a danielle gutierrez
that i i really she was a great support
all this time and she helped me
in all the different details through
more than two months i will say
danielle received a phd in history from
the university of puerto rico where she
won the medal of high academic
distinction in
2012. she's currently teaching writing
at princeton university she has
published in a number of distinguished
history journals and she will be this
coming summer a visiting fellow at
harvard university
so
welcome to everybody
[Applause]
good afternoon
it is an absolute privilege
to serve as moderator of an island under
siege
puerto rico's current financial
political and human rights crisis
i dare to speak
for today's panelists to also express
their sense of profound gratitude
nonetheless even though this sense of
appreciation
does have much to do with the provision
of an academic space
a
safe academic space to have such a
complex conversation
this gratitude does not only emerge from
academic inquiry
even though we're all invested in an
ongoing search for meaning as scholars
and communicators
our presentations have a thread
that is more urgent
and compelling
deep indignation
as the oversight board situates itself
as a source of authority in the island
puerto ricans seem to be under siege
by affirmative acts that have
historically belittled the right to
political representation
and deliberately augmented their fiscal
responsibility
under the rules of austerity
our invited speakers today have another
thing in common
we all share a story with the
universidad de puerto rico
when these roundtable discussions were
first conceived we could have not
envisioned
the circumstances that would be
contextualizing our contributions today
exactly a week ago the oversight board
was in an air-conditioned convention
center condescendently hearing proposals
of academic development while outside
the students of the university of puerto
rico held a protest under the sun
standing against the 450 million budget
cut
that would affect its accreditation
and would be fatal to its long narrative
of intellectual production and social
dissent
today the university of puerto rico
is still paralyzed by an ongoing strike
that started two days ago
a struggle to hold on to some sense of
puerto rican agency
these two fronts encompass the crux of
the divergences we will be analyzing
today
while the second session will look at
the crisis from the lenses of
intellectual history political history
and economic projections
this first roundtable discussion will
concentrate on looking at this vortex
from three angles first we will explore
the constitutional history that precedes
and fuels the terms and conditions of
the puerto rico oversight management and
economic stability act also known as
promesa next we will survey local media
representation of the crisis
lastly we will ponder on the human
rights implications of the oversight
board
each paper presentation will last
approximately 20 minutes after all
presentations there will be time for
questions and answers
our first presenter is dr refren rivera
ramos rivera ramos is a full professor
and former dean of the university of
puerto rico law school
recipient of the deborah
pro and public service of the american
association of law schools and the hey
haywood burns and shannara gilbert award
from the northeastern people of color
conference
he has been a visiting professor at yale
university
the university of otawa pompeo fabra
university in barcelona's university of
barcelona
his best publication record on the
constitutional history of puerto rico
has led him to participate in special
commissions of the supreme court of
puerto rico and to serve as a consultant
of the conflict prevention and peace
forum of the social science research
council and the political department of
the united nations
this inquest within the convoluted
constitutional history of puerto rico of
today's presentation
titled brief historical review of the
constitutional relationship between the
u.s
very close to
our intellectual
concerns and our passions
i want to thank the organizers
for setting up this program
and for inviting me
where i had such a wonderful time as a
visiting professor some years ago
and where i still have so so many dear
friends one of those here
we
have been asked to address
the current fiscal crisis in puerto rico
which as has
been said
and one of the things has led
to the establishment by the us congress
of a fiscal oversight board
that has taken over
the control of puerto rico's fiscal
and budgetary affairs
the fiscal crisis of puerto rico has
many dimensions
it involves historical
constitutional political
economic
social and human rights considerations
it touches on both law
and policy
since in health this afternoon there
will be other speakers who will address
in more detail
many of those issues i have decided
to dedicate my initial comments
this afternoon to providing a very
succinct and i underline succinct
summary
of the constitutional relationship
between the united states in order to
put in context
the adoption of the so-called promesa
legislation
that created the oversight board
and its reception in puerto rico
in the early years of the 20th century
the supreme court of the united states
determined
that puerto rico should be considered
what it called an
unincorporated territory of the united
states
the court also affirmed that
territories such as puerto rico
were subject to what it called the
plenary powers of congress
under
the territorial clause of the united
states constitution
and that clause
called the territorial clause reads and
i quote
the congress shall have power
to dispose of
and make
all needful rules and regulations
respecting the territory or other
property belonging to the united states
and of course i'll read it again
i'd like to read it
it reminds us of so many things
it has so many
connotations the congress shall have
power
to dispose of
and make all needful rules and
regulations respecting the territory
or other property
belonging to the united states and of
course
now what is this plenary power that
congress exercises over the territories
first the concept means
that congress has exclusive power
to take fundamental decisions
regarding the condition of the
territories
second
plenary powers are general powers of
government
in contrast to the limited powers that
congress may exercise over the states
in other words
congress can exert over the territory
power that it could not exercise over
the states
that is why
congress can adopt a law like promesa
to govern fiscal budgetary
and other key aspects of the government
of puerto rico
something it cannot do for the states
thirdly
there is a sense of plenary
elaborated by associate justice john
marshall harlan in in a 1907 case called
grafton v u.s
harlan wrote
that one of the differences between a
territory and a state
is
that the government of a state
does not derive its powers from the
united states
whereas
the government of a territory like
puerto rico
owes its existence
wholly to the united states
harlan said and i quote
the jurisdiction and authority of the
united states over that territory and
its inhabitants
for all legitimate purpose of government
is paramount
and of course
now it was in the exercise of its
plenary powers
that congress extended u.s citizenship
to puerto ricans in 1917
that it permitted puerto ricans to elect
our own governor in 1947
that it allowed puerto rico to draft its
own constitution in 1950
and
approved congress approved with
amendments the puerto rican constitution
of 1952
under its plenary power in 1976
congress passed
section 936
of the u.s international code
to provide tax exemptions to u.s firms
operating in puerto rico
giving the puerto rican economy a boost
in the following
and
under that very same plenary power
in 1996
congress eliminated section 936
causing an economic joke in the
territory whose consequences are felt to
this day
it has been
by virtue of its plenary power
under the territorial clause
that congress has placed caps
on the social and welfare pro
that it makes available to puerto rico
such as medicare and medicaid
providing for fewer benefits than those
accessible to residents of the states
congress can do that and it has done
that
to be sure
all those actions have had significant
long-term term effects on puerto rico's
political and economic life
and some of those histories
are closely tied
to diverse aspects of the crisis
after the adoption of the 1952
constitution and the proclamation of the
so-called commonwealth of puerto rico
many in puerto rico entertained the idea
that something in the relationship
in puerto rico
had fundamentally changed
that the latter puerto rico had ceased
to be
a mere territory of the u.s
then came
june
what happened in june
of 2016.
that month
the u.s supreme court
decided
two cases
that have been viewed by most people in
puerto rico
as a severe to the current commonwealth
status
one of those cases is known as
commonwealth v sanchez valley
in which the court concluded
that puerto rico had not become a
sovereign entity
for purposes of the double jeopardy
clause of the u.s constitution
now the double jeopardy clause
protects a person from being prosecuted
twice for the same offense
except
if the prosecutions are conducted by
different
puerto rico
the majority opinion in sanchez valley
likened
puerto rico's relationship to the united
states
to that
between a municipality
and the state that has granted the
municipality is chartered so puerto rico
is to the federal government
what a city
or a town is to the state that created
the city and the town
it is not the same as a relationship
between the state
and the federal government that's what
what it means
now the important thing is that in order
to reach its conclusion
the court emphasized the role that
congress played
in the enactment of the constitution of
puerto rico because congress authorized
its adoption
amended constitution approved by the
puerto rican people in significant ways
and finally
stamped its final approval on the text
so that was a role that congress played
that's the road that the court
um underlines as being dispositive
of
the question that it had
to resolve in that case
in a telling statement
the court added that and i quote
one power congress does not have
just in the nature of things
it has
no capacity
no magic wand or
airbrush to erase
or otherwise rewrite
its own foundational role
in conferring political authority
or otherwise said
the delegator congress
cannot make itself
any less so
no matter how much authority it opts to
hand over and of course
in other words
by acting to authorize puerto rico to
draft its own constitution
congress was not relinquishing its
powers
under the territorial
clause
it reserved those powers
in fact according to the court congress
could not relinquish its powers
the implication then is that puerto rico
despite 1952
is still to be considered a territory of
the u.s
and per definition
subject to the plenary powers of
congress
under that clause of the constitution
now four days later
after that case was decided
the supreme court decided another case
commonwealth the franklin that also had
to do with puerto rico
the case arose out of the following
circumstances
puerto rico had always been included
in chapter 9
of the u.s bankrupt bankruptcy code
which basically authorizes states
to
in turn authorize its municipalities
and instrumentalities
to file for bankruptcy in federal court
under chapter 9. puerto rico had always
been included in that because it had
always been
defined as a state for for that purpose
but in 1984
without explanation
congress excluded puerto rico from the
benefits of chapter 9 of the u.s
bankruptcy code
which meant that it was not authorized
puerto rico was not authorized to
authorize
its instrumentalities and municipalities
to take advantage of the provisions of
chapter nine of the bankruptcy code
now
in land in light of that exclusion
and in response to the
current
fiscal crisis
in 2014
puerto rico adopted its own bankruptcy
law
because it could not make itself avail
itself of the federal bankruptcy law
a group of creditors challenged that
puerto rican law
and finally the u.s supreme court
found in favor of the
challengers exciting that
although congress
had excluded puerto rico
from chapter nine
puerto rico was still bound
by that status provision
from adopting their own debt
restructuring status to force
non-consenting creditors to accept the
terms
of such adjustment adjustments in other
words
puerto rico could not avail itself of
chapter 9
and could not pass its own law to remedy
that deficiency
so puerto rico found itself between a
rock and a hard place
now the majority opinion in that case
does not address
any constitutional issues
such as the question of puerto rico's
political status it doesn't do that
expressly
but as it usually happens
the court
proceeds
under several constitutional assumptions
one such assumption
is that congress
may properly
exclude puerto rico from the benefits of
chapter nine
and of course
the only reason it can do so
is
because of its plenary powers under the
territorial clause
four days after the sanchez valiant
decision
and the very same day the franklin
decision was rendered
congress
enacted promesa
so the the very same day
the court decided franklin and that day
congress enacted promesa
what is promesa apart from a
perverse
irony on the pile
on the part of the drafters of the
statute apart from that what is
promesa it is a federal statute that
basically does three things
it creates
the so-called oversight and management
board
to control puerto rico's physical
budgetary affairs
the board's seven members
are appointed by the president
six of them
by recommendation of the majority and
minority leadership of the u.s congress
and one chosen by the president itself
now remember puerto rico does not vote
for the president and puerto rico does
not elect voting members
to congress voting representatives
in congress
so that's the first thing that promised
us it creates this board
i talk about it uh
a little more or the rule or regulation
is somehow incompatible with the fiscal
plan that the board itself has
authorized
the board
may require
that all of the puerto rican
government's contracts and financial
transactions be submitted to it for its
prior approval
so if the board decides so
the puerto rican government could not
contract make any enter into any
contract or enter into any transaction a
financial transaction without the
board's prior approval
the board may make recommendations to
the puerto rican government on a wide
variety of organizational and
operational matters
with the requirement that
if those recommendations are not adopted
by the puerto rican government
then the government has to provide an
explanation of its reasons to the board
to the president of the u.s and to the
u.s congress
the government is required to submit
quarterly reports to the board
on the implementation of the certified
certified fiscal plans and the budget
and the board has the power to require
adjustments
to
either the plan or the budget if it
finds that the government is not
operating in compliance
with either
okay
the board has
many other powers specified in the law
that
also
illustrate
the tremendous amount of power
that this entity
has been endowed with by the promesa
legislation
promesa in fact
displaces or suspends
numerous provisions of the constitution
of puerto rico
it is nothing less
the board
is nothing less
than a super government
composed of non-elected functionaries
operating
over and above
the duly elected government of puerto
rico
that's what promesa is about basically
and that's what the board is about
now what is especially relevant
to this brief historical review is that
promesa
expressly establishes
that the act has been enacted
pursuant to congress's powers under the
territorial clause of the u.s
constitution
if anyone had entertained any doubts
about the territorial nature of puerto
rico's government
and the extent of congressional power
over it
congress has unequivocally dispelled
those doubts
on the heels of the sanchez valley and
the franklin cases that's why those
three events are related those two cases
and the enactment of promisa
and this may explain to some extent
the negative reaction to promesa
by many sectors of puerto rican society
like the students
who view promesa and the oversight board
as another colonial imposition
that belies contemporary democratic
values
impinges upon the human rights of puerto
rico's most vulnerable populations
and undermines puerto rico's very right
to self-determination
if you have any questions i will gladly
address them during the discussion
period thank you
our next presenter is joining
gonzalez gonzalez is a journalist for
the business section of a new alien
and has earned a master's degree in
communications from the university of
puerto rico
during her 20-year
journalistic career she has artists
reported on the transformations and
downturns of puerto rico's recent
economic history her work has been
recognized by puerto rican business
organizations the overseas press club
and spain's ie business school her
determination toward casting light into
puerto rico's economic crisis frames
representation titled the story that
many refuse to believe puerto rico's
economic and institutional decay and the
role of local media in unveiling the
crisis
thank you thank you computer easier to
use
yeah daniel just left and he has his
password
let's proceed and
you want to go to that of course of
course
it's okay it's gonna be a complement of
your presentation i know
don't worry it's okay
well um good afternoon to all thank you
so much professor ordan uh your
colleagues at the center for organizing
this event and certainly for allowing me
to share my thoughts i've been writing
about this crisis for so long
i think
so it's it's nice to share my thoughts
although i would say that they're not
necessarily
the views or the opinions of el nuevo
dia or the gfr media which is the media
or the newspaper i worked for
i would say that pro-record is insolvent
in fact puerto rico has been insolvent
for nearly a decade
no it's over there and this is the
keyboard okay sorry but you could go on
my course
um
as i was saying for a request insolvent
it's been insolvent for nearly a decade
i would say
facts point to it
but people learn about it
maybe make your computer easier to use
[Laughter]
this is god
yes
some people learn about
puerto rico crisis in
um there was this
this publication i mean this barnes is a
very respected publication within the
financial world and suddenly our crisis
was
somehow summarized in that story
some of it
happened because detroit went bankrupt
and people started wondering if
there was another
issuer within the municipal market that
could face the same challenges
and
that
somehow
wasn't hurt by many
and three years
other people learn about puerto rico
crisis when president barack obama and
congress of course
a passage promise
and
that was was
that was what the president
former president obama said
um when he enacted the the bill
um when when they did that but by the
same
at the same time the white house really
is released uh some kind of a fact sheet
about promesa
and and if you read it it would say
things like
we won't see any layoffs within the
government
the ward is not allowed to
take the powers of elected officials and
so on
i won't go into the ad because i'm a
reporter and i'm just trying to stick to
the facts
well
now
this is where we are
there are 23 days
for the end of promesa's stay
when promesa was approved
it allowed all kinds of litigations
to
stay
until the parties meaning the government
and creditors could reach an agreement
but that period to
try to
strike a deal as people say within the
financial world
it's run and short so we're just 23 days
away from the end of from stay that
happens in may first
what will happen
well there's already about a dozen
lawsuits files against the government of
puerto rico
and as i said
they're
plain tips which are creditors they're
asking for several remedies or reliefs
they're asking things like
to revert
the way public funds have been used
since the default as a year
and they're also asking for
things like
newly find a specific law moratolium law
which was the one that allowed for the
government to default
what i see there
or what are you seeing there
it's something that it's extremely close
to what will happen at the in the court
we have right now
all these lawsuits are pending creditors
are waiting for their money
but there is an issue
there is no money
at the treasury account
and that's the forecast
what we are seeing there
is precisely
how the government is running short out
of money this is by the way i think that
it start right at this week
and it would go
until june 30th
i don't see too many
too many columns in the upside i think
that it's mostly negative
so the government according to the own
certified government figures and the
certified plan
for a week of government would be in red
by 279
million dollars next june
but that amount of money does not
include other things
like
the debt that we hasn't paid in two
years that's about two billion dollars
and it doesn't include
the fact that the government of puerto
rico will need to pay for pensions
starting next june
it doesn't include
either
the amount of money that puerto rico
will lose
once obamacare funds are extinguished
next october
so
i don't want to be rude
but the truth is that puerto rico needs
asap
at least 2 billion dollars in cash just
to keep things rolling
as you see there there are not too many
options
why the government of puerto rico will
start paying pensions well
you're seeing their the current state of
the teachers retirement system those
teachers they don't receive any other
income because they don't contribute to
social security
and you'll see in there
the public employee retirement system
assets as you see
both of them
are nearly depleted or in fact they're
going to be depleted
just in a couple of months in the case
of the public retirement system
that would be short
in june
teacher retirement systems will run out
of cash by next february february 2018 i
think
so
with this situation
the oversight board
said we have
a business or a financial solution
this is a figures we're talking about a
financial problem
and the board is providing a financial
solution and i want to make that clear
because
i know that the saddest part of this is
public discussion and all this debate is
that there's a human side that's the
site we've been writing over and over
and over again
but
that tragedy in fact is being handled as
a financial matter we're dealing with
creditors creators are asking for money
and the government would like to provide
services
for at the very end they don't have
enough money to do so
i know there's root but that's
how it's been played
the board was
very clear last january
when the board said
that puerto rico had to
make
a correction of its finances
and even though
if the
if the puerto rican government goes
ahead with a fiscal plan
it won't have money to pay creditors
puerto rico is supposed to pay creditors
about four billion dollars a year
according to the plan to the certified
plan
the board allowed for
for that purpose
only 800 million dollars
and that is really important because
although many people are saying that the
board
it's only here to ensure the creditors
get paid
it makes you wonder
how this is going to unfold because
at the very end
the board is also asking a very very
important sacrifice
to creditors and in fact they are the
ones who
have plenty of resources to challenge
promesa and to challenge the fiscal plan
not necessarily the people not the
citizens
but the creditors they will have all the
resources and they will make sure that
that 800 million figure figure goes up
once they go to court
some people think
that creditors
should bear the cost that's what we've
been seeing all over again
in every corner of puerto rico you would
see something like that
because people
don't believe that this is gonna happen
people are refusing
for these
and it seems inevitable so far
maybe we're gonna write something
different in a couple of weeks but still
we don't know that yet
that's the recipe
the board is asking for a combination of
revenues
and government cards
that is about
1.3 billion dollars
in revenue measures
and costs for 2.6 billion dollars and
that should happen in a three-year span
when you look at it only the cuts
that we represent and i know that
there's an economies and maybe i'm not
the right person to to say this but
but that amount of money would represent
about four percent of puerto rico's
cross product
that's what we're talking about
what has happened how come puerto rico
is in this situation
how come people didn't know what was
going on
well for many of us the crisis has been
our daily bread and butter
we've been writing about this
for nearly 10 to 11 years
in 2006
right after the government
shut down
and we got the first rating downgrade
we ran a story talking about what
happened to communities to cities and
counties
that did not handle their finances well
that's a story talking about the case of
washington d.c
in the case of philadelphia when no one
was talking about a fiscal control board
we set the record straight
when no one was talking about what could
happen in terms of running short of
money
we did run a story
unfortunately
i think that
people refused to believe
three governors told us over and over
again that the finances were fixed
this is a story from november 2016
pointing
that the deficit the fiscal imbalances
continue
so nothing has been addressed properly
this is something that i
i want every i want i think i won't ever
forget this day
that was in 2010.
gentleman over there is mr carlos garcia
he's one of the current members of the
oversight board
then he was chair at the government
development bank
he went to the legislator
and he said we were able to arrange this
new mechanism through kofina they made
an amendment kofina is a
an entity that issues that that is paid
with with the sales tax
and he warned lawmakers then and he said
the government of puerto rico is going
to run out of money it's going to run
out of money and it's going to be quite
soon
i don't know i think that the place was
packed
there were plenty of reporters over
there
tv radio but i think that no one got the
message
as i said
we have never addressed our fiscal
imbalances
and for some people and in some part it
makes sense governors governments not
necessarily need to deal
a fist with a balanced budget
but when the fiscal cap
is a continuous trend
there's no way you can provide services
to people
if you're not handling your finances
properly that's the story of the general
fund
i think that they're there maybe 12
years
always in rent
and people won't believe this either
people got a rescue package
the people of puerto rico got it
it didn't have that name
but between
2009 and 2011
a lot of things happened in puerto rico
that maybe
were not so significant or maybe people
didn't thought it was important
we had a banking crisis the fdic jumped
in
supporting with about 8 billion 8
billion dollars in deposits
we had our funds which was a stimulus
package
provided by president obama
that figure was about
six billion
we also had
tarp funds
two local banks had access to the
program created during the financial
crisis
and we also had
obamacare
and the irs never questioned a new
excise tax imposed by the government of
puerto rico
in the case of the excise tax that would
represent another six billion dollars in
a six year span
and in the case of the error funds it
was about seven billion dollars
obamacare nearly seven billion dollars
more
that amount of money has banished
but when you look at those
that tremendous amount of money people
who know about these things
what puerto rico got in those
four years
it's similar to what greece received
from the imf
during the first part of the crisis
still
in 2012
we took a look at the finances of puerto
rico
and we ran this
very i would say
alarming
cover story for our paper because we're
like the paper of record so so we don't
try to be
too sensationalist
ran that story
saying that was in april 2012
saying that puerto rico will run out of
money
by 2015.
to my dismay
we made an analysis back then
we told the people
how much that was issued
we had the opportunity of interviewing
experts economies people who have been
following puerto rico for a long time
and they all agreed
we were headed to a cul-de-sac
to my dismay we were right
in july
2015
the government of puerto rico defaulted
for the very first time of its history
by not paying the public finance
corporation dead
it's not easy
reporting about this
sometimes one of the reasons is so
difficult is because it's about numbers
or it's about reading hundreds and
hundreds of financial statements
most of the import most of the important
things are buried in footnotes
that only investors
attorneys read
because they care about their clients
but the people don't read about these
things
and many experts either
so
in fact there were decay
the way the
finances were simply
tearing apart
was was buried within the financial
statements but they're complicated
things that citizens are not necessarily
familiar with
and another thing is that puerto rico is
not necessarily
too responsible
it seems that it doesn't manage its
finances well but it doesn't comply with
regulations either
that fact over there
i think that is very very important
for an issuer to
for a municipal issuer
to go and raise capital from the markets
it must comply with certain criteria
one of the things it should comply
is to provide its financial statements
on a timely basis
well
puerto rico has 305 years
days after the closing of each fiscal
year to do so
take a look
at first it didn't
go so bad
look at what happened in 2008 in 2009
look what happened
in 2014
that's how many days you're behind from
your required deadline
right now puerto rico hasn't released
any other financial statements since
fiscal year 2014. we're missing 2015
2016
and now 2017
but still we still have time
some people did pay attention
some people did see what's what's going
on and some people like in the case this
very good friend planeta
and and some of his work has been
portrayed at the chanta grados he tried
to explain people that in fact
all of these could be explained by
something
and that is the economy
puerto rico
has been contracting constantly i don't
go into the detail with because there's
someone who is going to take care of
that
but the truth is that there is no way
you can run a government if you cannot
raise revenues
and it's very difficult in the case of
puerto rico
i think that
one of the persons who explained that
brilliantly is precisely economies
francisco catala
one of the reasons the economy is
performing so badly is because our
entire institutional framework is
falling apart
we keep doing things like the way they
were supposed to they were done
30 years ago and we keep promoting
policies that didn't
that didn't result in good benefits for
puerto rico
puerto rico had a lot of tax exempt
incentives
and what the government is proposing to
reinvest to reignite the economy another
version of 936.
we think that people should buy houses
so we go ahead and we
borrow money to create some kind of a
bonus so people could buy houses
how people could buy houses if they
don't have a job
to pay for their mortgages
but we keep doing this
and it's very difficult to do it it's
very difficult to provide good services
to the population when only one people
who is in working age
one or four people
at working age is doing so in puerto
rico
there's no way you can run a government
there's no way you can provide services
to the people
with such a small base
and i'm going to go quite fast with why
fight back with this
two things
that i that were evident and that for
some reason people didn't realize
is that puerto rico went
into a very serious financial crisis
as i said in 2020 in 2010 sorry
three banks failed
that was the third part of the financial
system
but it was so important that those
failures are among the top 25 largest
failures of the 2008 fiscal crisis of
the united states financial crisis
but
no one was paying attention
that resulted
in tremendous losses in the case of the
shareholders of the banks they lost
about eight billion dollars
that
happened in part because we went
through a housing bubble
the housing bubble turned into a bust
and people started losing
what they saved
property values has not recovered since
then
there is an example over there
but the saddest part and i'm gonna
finish right now
okay yes
is that people are losing their houses
every single day
about 10 families lose their homes every
single day per week but no one's
pays attention
and i'm gonna
live with this
the governor said governor garcia
pavilla said
that he was ready to go ahead
and to solve the island crisis
he was the one who lobbied for promesa
along with entrepreneurs
along with the business community
we ended with a restructuring vehicle
but also with an oversight board
precisely because because the government
the solution to the crisis
was providing that mechanism for the
people of puerto rico
thank you
our final presenter for this session is
ariata
albert codero albert is an adjunct
professor at the universidades agrado
corazon in puerto rico has earned a
jurisdictor of the university of puerto
rico and is currently pursuing a
master's degree in international human
rights
at the university of oxford
she has served as coordinator of the
access to justice working group and is a
member of the legal action committee
which represents protesters of promesa
her master thesis aims to analyze the
adequacy of international law to attend
to sustainable depth to unsustainable
debt in college in colonies
along that line today's presentation is
titled
people before depth promesa and the
primacy of human rights in the wake of
austerity thank you
i wanted to start by
saying how grateful i am to be here
thank you to professor maria gordan and
for everybody
to be here and to the people that's
online following this conference
as daniel was saying i'm going to be
speaking from
the perspective of a human rights lawyer
and i wanted to make that disclosure
beforehand
so prior and after the approval of
promesa i have had the opportunity to
collaborate as an activist and a lawyer
participating in popular education
efforts joining anti-promesa rallies and
providing legal support to protesters
against the hunter
lately i have been studying the public
debt from an international human rights
perspective but also as a
socio-political and gendered issue as a
continuum of colonialism
today i will share some brief
reflections of theme on the impact of
promesa and australia on the social and
economic rights of those living in
puerto rico
i wanted to start by highlighting some
key elements for this discussion
first that according to promesa the
junta has two main objectives first to
guarantee the repayment of the debt and
to restore and to restore pr's access to
financial markets
although it directly affects labor
health education and environmental
rights promesa never attends to human
rights mention mentions of rights and
you can
find the word
rights in a pdf version and serious
mention of rights are limited to those
of the creditors and two obligations
arising from lending contracts
this has led many to sustain that the
junta is nothing but a collection agency
secondly the laws of democracy places
the question of what's in a name in a
central position
tejunta the board is a fiscal control
board and not an oversight board this
unelected body has taken over puerto
rico's budget public policies agencies
public corporations and even the
university and this is important because
the distance between oversight and
control is proportional to the gap
between democracy and colonialism
this is also relevant in human rights
terms by assuming virtually absolute
control over puerto rico's government
the junta contracted a direct
responsibility towards the enjoyment of
human rights in the island that being
said in this presentation i will argue
that first puerto rico has engaged in a
pattern of self-defeating australia the
crisis did not start or will end with
promesa this is a crisis rooted in
colonialism inequality poor economic
growth strategies and in the lack of a
nationally defined social protection
floor
two as many examples illustrate promesa
jeopardizes social and economic rights
by increasing austerity it challenges
the primacy of human rights by
prioritizing financial reputation and
practicum servanda debt service over
fundamental guarantees
third that puerto rico and the u.s
governments have a responsibility to
protect respect and fulfill the rights
of those living in puerto rico and this
responsibility extends to private actors
such as creditors banks and vulture
funds
fourth that puerto rico's debt crisis
requires a human rights-based approach
in which principles such as dignity
participation non-discrimination
transparency and equitable development
are accounted for
this approach also speaks of monitoring
accountability naming those responsible
and access to adequate remedies to those
who suffer violations
and lastly
international human rights law must
adapt modify create develop forums and
remedies suitable for those living in
unresolved colonial lands like puerto
rico
during the past two decades
international organizations have
developed a framework to assess
unsustainability from a human rights
perspective
these efforts have been pushed forward
by the u.n and particularly by the
independent expert on the impact of
foreign debt in economic and social
rights
as joanna de isabel was saying debt
management strategies rarely take human
rights into consideration
and as we all know the u.s has not
ratified most major human rights
treaties like isesca or sedo and even
more the u.s as we were talking before
coming here has opposed on several
occasions to the into the mandate of the
independent expert confirming that
arguing that debt should not be assessed
from a human rights perspective
uh so most of the principles that i'm
going to be discussing here
they are not legally enforceable
but these guidelines are useful to
analyze the impact of australia and
promesa
a human rights-based approach uh to
unsustainable debt provides a
comprehensive understanding of austerity
and its consequences this approach
accounts for the duty better
right-holder relationships between
creditors the state and the people
although when faced with with serious
economic hardship a state may have no
other option than than to downgrade or
limit the level of enjoyment of a right
austerity cannot be implemented blindly
to be legitimate australian measures
must comply with a specific criteria
austerity measures must must be
necessary reasonable temporary
proportional non-discriminatory protect
a minimum corrupt rights and promote the
genuine participation of those affected
the interdependency of rights must also
be accounted for
neither can such as the adjustment be a
mean to derive profit and aggravate the
inequality by increasing the gap between
the rich who become richer because of
the crisis and those who become poor
as spain and greece demonstrate
austerity is an ineffective mechanism of
economic growth and has detrimental
consequences on the rights and living
conditions of vulnerable populations
since 2006 puerto rico has experienced
aggravated australia there was an
increase in sale and property taxes and
in the cost of essential services major
layoff plans were implemented schools
were closed public housing residents
evicted and health services privatized
meanwhile the government tailored
policies to attract investors many of
them regardless of the consequences for
the island populations
laws such as law 20 and 22 which will be
probably discussed in the
next panel presented puerto rico as a
tropical tax haven with no passport
requirement and cheap labor force while
the scarce money available was being
diverted to the debt more loans were
being taken and soon even when most of
the public expenditure was being
destined to health educational tensions
the crisis became undeniable poor
management and lack of accountability
led many to consider that it was the
government who forged the crisis
as of today and somehow to respond to
who has been paying attention to the
crisis
45.2 of the population lives under
poverty in municipalities like salinas
this number reaches 60 percent
inequality it's also increasing puerto
rico is the second most unequal place in
latin america and also second in the us
81 percent of children live in high
poverty areas 48 percent of women and 40
percent of those 65 year years old or
older live under poverty
50 percent of the population benefits
from the public health plan 1.3 million
people receive food stamps in the last
decade nearly 10 percent of the
population left the island and contrary
to the brain drain myth between 2006 and
2014
nearly 250 000 of those peoples were
poor the working class is living while
statistica while statistics is
statistics while statistics are not
reliable and do not provide a
comprehensive understanding of a human
rights crisis these numbers are telling
now i wanted to share some example of
the consequences of australia in three
fundamental rights education labor and
access to justice i want to illustrate
the already fragile ecosystem in which
promesa proposes more budget cuts and a
debt service driven plan
many of these findings were presented
before the inter-american commission on
human rights uh last year
and uh they are also i also incorporated
part of the fiscal plan that was just
approved by the junta
in regards to education the public
system has been under siege for the past
10 years between 2014 and 2016
177 schools were closed
according to the fiscal plan 300 more
schools are to be closed now in august
while the government justifies these
actions by signaling to a reduction of
students parents teachers and
communities have been denied
participation in these decisions even
when when they could demonstrate that
schools had sufficient enrollment
academic achievements and were
inadequate conditions many of these
shutdowns happened days before the
beginning of the semester without prior
notification fostering an atmosphere of
uncertainty and vulnerability for these
children and their families the case of
special education is particularly
disheartening between 25 to 30 percent
of the students in puerto rico are
registered as special education students
while many factors could explain this
statistic it is undeniable that the
government has been unable to provide
adequate education for thousands of
children with diverse mental and
physical conditions who lack t-shirts
therapists and suitable learning
facilities for the past 35 years in the
rosalind versus departamento educacion
case before the district court of puerto
rico
families have been fighting to make the
puerto rico government fulfill its duty
towards the adequate education of these
children
instead for ten years the government has
preferred to pay ten thousand
ten ten thousand dollars daily fine for
non-compliance there is no information
in the fiscal plan on what is going to
be made with the special education
students the right to labor has also
been affected major layoffs in the
government implemented in the last
decade have had direct repercussions in
the economy summing up to the loss of
230 000 jobs in the private and public
sector together
as of today only 4 out of 10 able puerto
ricans are active in the labor force
promesa promises more precarity for
workers the junta has power to revise
labor policies intervening collective
bargaining agreements and forbid strikes
the labor reform approach approved in
february in compliance with the home
task recommendations includes a
reduction in
vacation leaves the extension of
probationary periods for new workers and
hinders claims for unfair employment
termination
while groups abroad advocate for living
wages under promesa the government the
governor has discretion to lower the
minimum wage of those 25 years and
younger to four dollars and 25 cents
this amounts to 170 dollars per week
before taxes making puerto rico the
cheapest labor market within the us this
fulfills the demands of private sector
coalitions who have for long advocated
for lower wages arguing that the minimum
wage hinders economic growth and that it
is too high in relation to the skills of
the people in puerto rico
this will result in increasing poverty
violence and out-migration the pension
system is also at risk while both the
government and creditors have tried to
construct a narrative using pensioners
who are also bond holders to justify
debt service the sustainability of the
pension system is extremely precarious
as of today thirty thousand elders
survive on barely five hundred dollars
or less a month
with twenty three percent of the
population being sixty years old or
older promise a lack of compromise with
the protection of the pension system is
of considerable concern
the fiscal plan includes a reduction of
10 percent in all public pensions
lastly an access to justice the
government is increasingly unable to
provide adequate conditions for the
exercise of rights inside and outside
the courts
budget cuts in the judicial branch have
justified the shutdowns of courts in
high poverty areas together with a
failed public transportation and crime
prevention system this means less access
to justice for the poor domestic
violence survivors elders and disabled
among others free legal services
providers have experienced budget costs
of 30 to 40 percent
eviction and foreclosure cases have been
increasing by thousands and in the
majority of these cases up to 90 percent
the defendants like legal representation
access to justice also means access to
remedies
the immunity granted
in promesa is a cause for great concern
as well as the repression of the right
to protest mobilizations under the
slogan people before death has been
instrumental to boys opposition to
australia and promesa as danielle was
saying while we are here students in the
university of puerto rico the only
higher public education in puerto rico
have declared a systemic strike
protesting the fiscal plan's intended
major budget cut to the institution the
imposition of the hunter australia and
demanding a public audit to the depth in
response private actors like walmart
media conglomerates the chamber of
commerce assisted by the government have
attempted to use litigation to prohibit
free speech
at this moment the pr legislature is
considering amending the penal code to
criminalize protests in education
facilities and in construction sites and
also observers and lawyers who by
attempting to mediate may delay police
interventions the possibility of more
frequent scenarios of police brutality
in the context of a very slow police
reform is a cause of alarm
colonialism produces vulnerability shown
by the imposition of the junta itself by
domestic restructuring mechanism being
struck down as a friend was saying it is
also important to know that
since 1953 puerto rico is not part of
the list of colonies so it's like a
double invisibility
colonialism also produces apathy while
many simplify the juntas and other
materialization of the colony for others
it is a chance to get even with
ineffective governments and corrupt
political parties
apathy endanger human endangers human
rights while the consequences of promesa
are yet to be seen it is clear that an
increasing number of people are not
going to survive in dignity the harsh
conditions and lack of essential
services that are coming it is in this
context that human rights decolonized
human rights discourses and practices
are essential first to make the
violations and injuries visible and
secondly to name the responsible and
third
to respond and to assess uh what are the
reactions to the debt crisis how do how
should they look like the government has
a primary responsibility towards the
enjoyment of human rights of those
living in puerto rico and as i said
before this responsibility extends to
the u.s government the junta the
creditors the vultures who own 40 to 50
percent of puerto rico's death and
budgetary discipline cannot be carried
out regardless of human rights as i said
human rights can help us assess how the
u.s and pr are reacting to the debt
crisis and translate our demands into
measurable and somehow universal claims
against austerity and inequality within
indebtedness the slogan people before
depth stands for real effective and
genuine participation one that includes
a public debt audit and the revision of
contracts laws and policies that promote
profit for some and inequality for most
guided by principles of human dignity
and self-determination
participation is not achieved by live
streaming open meetings or by publishing
financial analysis
what people demand is real
accountability naming the responsible
and stopping immunity and this is
something that has been carried out by
the hedge clippers an organization based
in the u.s that has been
investigating vulture funds for a while
and that just published a report naming
carlos garcia the man in the picture
that joni savelle projected
who is also a member of the control
board as well as other members of the
junta as part of the people who uh
who are responsible for the debt and
that that part accountability is also
very important from a human rights
perspective
the primacy of human rights obliged
questioning the legitimacy of acts that
render people unequal and colon and
colonized those being illegitimate
lending contracts audio steps the
imposition of la junta or the
exploitation of puerto rico and lastly i
just wanted to say that attending to the
crisis cannot be a justification for
intervention or aggravated conditions of
colonialism and that the answer may be
in the agency of people that for long
have been paying attention to the debt
crisis because i have been suffering the
the impact of the debt crisis for more
uh for way way way way before that the
junta was that promesa was passed so
that's it thank you
[Applause]
now we open the floor for questions from
the audience
um thank you those were amazing
presentations
yeah
those were terrific presentations um
thank you so much for them
just two questions
um one this from someone who's not
particularly well informed about puerto
rico um i'm
so striking that the kind of colonial
kind of situation is so
so brought into sharp relief by the
promesa
program and so on i just wonder what the
impact is on the kind of
debates and discussions and plans about
the
you know status of puerto rico and
future possible changes in that status
and then a question mostly i think
foreign is if you could talk a little
bit more about the what um ariana was
just talking about the
is your newspaper doing research is it
doing invest investigating kind of what
happened to the funds if you could tell
us a little about or anyone could tell
us a little bit about you know how that
divvy's up you know what went to what
kinds of um
wasteful or non-wasteful expenditures
and and uh that would be of great
interest thank you
the one with status i guess yes i guess
well about the
effect of promesa on the on the status
debate
um
well that's that's a very important
question i think it has had a
substantial effect i mean after the
passage of promesa
i think most people in puerto rico from
different
ideological sectors
have become more aware
of the tremendous power that congress
exerts over puerto rico
and the kinds of things that it can do
the fact that it had not done
something like that before doesn't mean
that it didn't have the power to do it
and it might do even much uh terrible
things in in the future
um so
i think in in that sense promesa has
lightened up the
status debate in fact
next june
june 11th there will be a referendum in
puerto rico
approved by the current government
in which the question will be submitted
to the population
in these terms that people will be asked
to vote either for statehood or for a
sort of a joint alternative called
independence or free association
numb together
so there will be a referendum now
whether
it probably won't be a binding
referendum
so we've had several of those in the
past
and uh nothing has happened
uh
also the
the the major position party in puerto
rico the public democratic party
is questioning the referendum because
the commonwealth option has not been
included in the ballot
so they are now they don't know what to
do and actually that was
one of the purposes of of this
of this referendum to sort of throw the
popularity of their base
uh
so
they are discussing you know what to do
regarding the referendum whether they
will abstain
whether they will participate but
ask their voters to
submit bank bank ballots uh whether they
group of them targeting for
the estado libri estado vista to vote
for the independence free association
option so there are several
and then there's another position
there's basically about four positions
another position is
for the party just to
leave
their
members uh free to do whatever they want
um they they're supposed to make a
decision on that so
whatever the the decision is that might
have an impact on how the
referendum results will be interpreted
also and also um
the
congress
passed what basically was a writer in
one in a
previous legislation assigning 2.5
million dollars to puerto rico to
conduct a
referendum if puerto rico wanted
the condition was that
if the money was used
it would be used for education purposes
but then the ballot would have to have
the approval of the attorney general of
the u.s
so the attorney general of the u.s would
have to pass judgment on whether
the alternatives on the ballot are
constitutional and
are
consequent to u.s policy those are the
two two conditions we don't know what
sessions is going to do with that
so and and we don't know what effect
would that have
on on the referendum process
but you know to go back to
your initial questions yes yes this has
had a
i think a significant impact on the
status debate in puerto rico
regarding the question about what has
happened with this huge amount of debt
i'll go quickly into three things
first
per week of that is federal
um
state
exempt
so in order to issue that pure
recommends fulfill with the criteria
of the 103 market
and then they could raise capital
with institutional or individuals
i say this because most of the issues
most of the debt this right issue
was precisely to build roads schools or
to to build a convention center
or uh
a new arena
but the question is if that was
necessary
or if it was
timely and it was the best solution
that's one of the issues
there was another one and it was that at
some point puerto rico started issuing
debt
to finance credit expenses
that happened between
2007 and kept going until 2013.
when people started asking questions
about that they passed the law
so they the lawmakers decided that you
could just go ahead
take a 30-year
loan
to pay for
computers and
cars and
lights at
baseball parks
and third
we've reported about
different aspects because we think that
there are things that deserve more
explaining for example the way the
constitutional margin has been
calculated throughout the years
now we see that creditors as precisely
in order to to get a piece of the pie
creditors are blaming each other
i'm saying the way that formula was
applied was incorrectly
the other party saying well
they created these new entities
that the debt would be paid with the
sales tax that was against the law
i'm not so sure if accord will have the
chance to preview that it would be
wonderful
um but we don't necessarily know if
that's that's the way it has been that
has happened before it happened in
detroit but by the by the time
that that dead was about to
somehow
be decided if it was new or not the
parties decided to
find a deal
so the judge didn't have to make a
decision
we also raised account uh certain
stories because in the case of the
pension systems the way to rescue this
pension system was
allowing the retirement system to issue
debt
but when we started digging on the
transaction
we found that some of the parties that
envisioned the transaction that designed
the transaction
also sell the transaction and also
bought the transaction the bonds through
another entity
but in the case of puerto rico we're not
regulated by the sec
those funds aren't really i'm regulated
in fact
about 22 billion dollars of puerto rica
debt was issued to local holders
and those funds but that debt
why because those investment companies
are not required to comply with federal
criteria
if puerto rico funds would have been
supervised by the fc by the sec
i bet we have we wouldn't have reached
70 million dollars in that but
unfortunately we weren't
so we've been writing about
we've been reporting the center for
investigative journalism also has
written a couple of pieces trying to dig
on who's owning puerto rico's debt now
we've been writing and and i hope that
it goes further
now than maybe that the public audit
commission
could proceed with their job that was
something that was authorized during the
past government
but
the current governor decided it was
unnecessary until a new
a judge said that
the audited of the public that should
should proceed
thank you very much
a question in the back yeah
yeah um so thank you for your
presentations um
now you mentioned considering puerto
rico's situation in an international
human rights context
you mentioned the situation as an
extension of the legacy of colonialism
are there other cases in their
international human rights sphere where
a nation state makes a claim against the
colonial powers and how that might
relate to the situation in puerto rico
yeah
of course
but one of the
major obstacles is that as i was saying
before and
maybe to elaborate on what a friend was
saying puerto rico is not part of the
list of non-governing territories so the
special decolonization committee of the
united nations which is the committee
that attends violations made by
national territories among others
it's not able to attend uh
more than the
the our claim like to be recognized as a
colony
since 1972 or maybe uh someone can
correct me here with the numbers we have
gone every single year to the
colonization committee and the
the committee has uh
made published 35 releases saying
basically the same that the general
assembly has to attend to the issue of
puerto rico
and the last time last year even the
current governor went and they placed
the debt crisis in the context of
undergoing colonialism and they also
mentioned the lack of available forms
like to be able to discuss the debt
and uh every time that uh the the
committee approves the resolution uh the
united states uh prevents it from being
discussing in the general assembly
because the argument is that in 1953
when the commonwealth was established
and the puerto rico constitution was
passed
the issue was resolved and that's the
thing another thing is that of there are
available forums like the commission of
the inter-american commission of human
rights but
that commission can give recommendations
to the us so we cannot put sanctions and
there's no really access to remedies so
that's another obstacle
professor sharks so to extend that that
uh
that question and your answer
um
the decision that was then made the two
decisions that were then made in the
supreme court
uh have revealed that in fact
uh the colonial
situation exists
uh in the past and from the 1950s on
countries like cuba for example often
brought the case of puerto rico to the
to the united nations so now with these
new decisions with the supreme court it
would seem that there might be
another opportunity to to bring the case
again
as an extension of that what about the
situation of the virgin islands
how does it differ from puerto rico in
terms for example of of uh its ability
to
to restructure its to restructure its
debt is it under the same is it under
the same conditions okay
let me
say something about the first part
[Music]
we have to clarify something in 1953
after the commonwealth was adopted the
u.s notified
the u.n that it would not submit any
more reports about puerto rico as
required by the u.n charter for those
countries that had
non-autonomous
territories under their control
so the u.s just notified that and then
the u.n passed a resolution
taking notice and basically basically
agreeing to that
but that happened
before 1960
and in 1960 the u.n
general assembly
adopted what is called as the magna
carta
of the colonization
which is resolution 15 14 15
14. uh
which basically called
for
all
colonial powers
to transfer
sovereign powers to
their
colonies and but the the phrasing was to
all those
that still had
non-autonomous territories under their
under their jurisdiction
and others who have not yet attained
independence
and it is under that
provision others that have not yet
attained their independence that puerto
rico was able
to fall into the jurisdiction of the u.n
decolonization committee
and so the und colonization committee
does have jurisdiction over puerto rico
it has assumed jurisdiction over puerto
rico and it has adopted all these
resolutions that uh aliena was talking
about and they have recommended that
that the un general assembly take up the
issue again to review it's the position
that it had adopted in 1953 that hasn't
happened yet but
every year salient says you know more
and more groups go to the event
equalization committee to press for
for
a new u.n intervention
now that's uh
regarding that that that issue
so um
and regarding the virgin islands um
promesa
is
a law that applies to all the
territories
uh
and it says that if a territory if the
government of territory
asked for
a special control board to be
established then it can be established
but under the condition that the
territorial government asked for it
solicits the creation of the board but
in the case of puerto rico it just
determined but we are hereby creating
the board for puerto rico so puerto rico
in fact was treated
in a less favorable fashion in that
sense than the other four
us territories which are expressed
expressly mentioned in the promesa
legislation
in the part of the definitions it says
by territory we mean
puerto rico american samoa mariana
islands and northern mariana islands um
the u.s virgin islands
so uh it does apply to
to to the territories but under that
condition
uh so
if the virgin islands government wanted
they would have a control board but if
they don't ask for it then it won't be
created
uh first of all thank you for
to the macmillan center for this is
fantastic
and secondly my question is to join
isabel gonzalez
um janice well my question is do you see
a correlation between the 1926
act faced out by the u.s congress
and all this puerto rico's scenario
yes
but i would say that it's not
necessarily as
important as many think
um i know that i'm aware of professor
rivera but jesus said i'm also aware
that for many people
section 936 was was a great thing for
the economy of puerto rico
but the truth is that
there is certain
there's there's certain literature
that points that that wasn't the case
the benefits of section 936
for the economy of puerto rico were much
less than the benefits that all these
pharmaceutical or not and and
manufacturing companies got from this
preferential treatment
when the congress decided to end
section 936 it did it because it wasn't
there the premise that those
manufacturing companies would start
paying taxes at the federal level but it
didn't happen what happened was that
those companies
evolved
and they kept doing business in puerto
rico or they've moved overseas they've
moved to europe they've moved to asia
but in ireland as well
but there's another important thing that
for me but it's really important with
the section 936 and maybe this is
something that not too many people
realize
is that
section 936 required these companies to
hold part of their monies within the
local banking industry
and that money fueled the banking system
to a level that we have not expected
unfortunately that source of funds
would have been served
to create a tremendous striving economy
but it didn't happen it just helped to
create the housing bubble the commercial
bubble the construction bubble that we
went through
but moreover
936 funds were deposited within the
government's development bank
so the government used those monies
to allow for a lot of infrastructure
projects and a lot and a lot of these
wishful thinking wonderful big
projects that majors and governors want
to have as a legacy
when the section 936 phase out
those monies
vanished the government decided to cover
that loophole with its own debt
i just wanted to clarify when i
mentioned 936 i was not arguing that it
was i know i know i was just trying to
illustrate yes yes the kind of
you know plenary powers that the
congress does that it can create 9 36
and then 20 years later later eliminate
it and then you know
so it's we're subject to all you know
those variations agree
thought
was it wise to
eliminate it eventually or were there oh
i mean we're not going to go back now
but uh to that
but i i need to understand if that was a
mistake or if that was the turning point
or if that was us
or if it is called a turning point but
it isn't so can someone clarify to me
well maybe maybe
i can address that okay
[Laughter]
maybe one should say that it did have
some effect
but not
you can correct me
this general
statement i'm going to make but not the
but it didn't meet the expectations
uh that people especially the government
placed on that program because one thing
that it i understand that i didn't do
and you correct me
professor is that it failed to
generate the kind of local linkages
that were
projected into
local enterprises linked to the to the
936 companies that would then contribute
to sort of internal internal growth and
development and that didn't happen as i
understand it that didn't happen and
that was one of the problems with with
the 1936 program yes but at the very end
936 it's only another version of 901
956.
now we're talking about 199
and that's the reason i mentioned the
thing with the institutional framework
and how it's been uh how it's how it's
been taken being apart because
you're thinking that by creating these
tremendous preferential tax treatments
companies are going to come and they're
going to create jobs
and it seems that that's the case so
we'll see i guess that professor alameda
would be mastering that subject
the thing is that
you need a substitution
and we never had a substitution
we never had a an alternative to 936. uh
maybe you have benefit from lying
certification maybe you have cause
hey this is right all of this is
coaching is right but we never built up
any substitution a framework that
substitutes that framework and this is
the wrong way yes
and we didn't pay attention to trade
agreements and how those trade
agreements transformed
the way companies operate and the way
countries do business so this besides
936 we were totally clueless about nafta
we're still wondering what will happen
if cuba decides to start new businesses
and to become a a powerful economy
within the region
we're not necessarily into that stage
unfortunately
so yes
yeah my question is about first of all
thank you to everyone my question is
more about the political climate
we're all aware of the divisive or
extremely devastating time in puerto
rico made even more so than the u.s
and to me based on that the results of
the 2016 election were puzzling in the
sense that i didn't see the backlash
that i thought i would see against the
traditional political players even
though there were new new people on the
scene who got it
and got to 10 which is probably more
than any
third party candidate or an alternative
even then the it would have been amazing
if that 10 had come to someone with an
anti-corporate discourse rather than a
corporate sounding
which sounds familiar in the us also
right in terms of how that outsider
comes in but i was wondering if it was
just too early for that backlash to come
in 2016 too close to the implementation
of la
and if we can see that in the next
elections and if it's going to move away
from traditional independence
or if we're stuck with that for a while
but
also one moment could we have also there
was also another member of the audience
i had a question could we have also the
question so we can
i'm not
i'm not famous among my closest friends
for being
short-winded so i'll try very hard to
limit myself to
two minutes
that's right
i'd like to word my question the same
way most people do who ask questions
they tell you what their answer is
and
so
i will um
address this to ms gonzalez
because he gave the broadest overview
and i have to ask one of the three of
you for the answer
the only right
i have to talk at all is i have two
puerto rican
grandchildren who are
17 and 19
and if everybody is as smart as those
kids
um
i hope they grow up fast because i know
they have the answer to everything
i wonder
how any of us can presume
to answer anything when the state of
connecticut is in such deplorable shape
and
it's hard for me to respond to because
i am so old and i'm falling apart at the
same time the whole world is falling
apart
and
nobody has an answer and the whole world
is so much in debt
we really need a new economic system
another 45 seconds
that's all
um
i don't know how we expect and i don't
know how puerto rico i have only had one
yale classmate uh carlos romero and i
forget
though
i like him and i talked with him now and
then and i don't know what his
reputation is with all of you okay
oh i better go fast
you could finish for me
but
um i've been to puerto rico only twice
and i had a wonderful time and everybody
was so thoughtful to me
but i i think
the politicians are not the ones to do
the work that the economists
really need to do
and
i think
it's so important to find somebody who
can
advise and be
be made a kind of a cabinet
to the government
because more and more
the government and all of you may be
governors of puerto rico and i apologize
for my
stupidity but
i don't think the politicians are going
to solve this because they don't they
cannot deliver bad news
the way it can in your own home
when you're going broke and you
you know you have to do something you
have to stop spending money and you have
to find a way so i would think
that
in puerto rico
an economist board
has to be made responsible i think there
has to be somebody who can be
accountable who can
invest in
the equivalent of investing in
connecticut and invest in puerto rico
and when there are results make it for
profit and motivate people that way
it's realistic maybe to reevaluate what
the wonderful things are of puerto rico
and the whole world is trying to do this
and
like tourism and i'm sure you've worked
on that but i've seen no place
except for five days a year when the
hurricanes come through
and i wonder if you can't
do a lot more
[Music]
with
tourism
and
drive
and make somebody more accountable sorry
i apologize no it's okay all right thank
you so much thank you hello thank you
i'm sorry no no thank you i know that
professor ahmed is gonna talk about the
possibilities of puerto rico and i know
that tourism sector certainly could be
uh could be a more important player
within the entire economy
i do have to say
that
there's been throughout time there's
been a lot of different efforts
there's been certain initiatives from
one governor and other governors
creating economic councils creating task
force to identify how to recognize the
economy
but we are
unable to
take those to make those processes
our own
and
provide continuity to those initiatives
for some reason that i don't understand
and maybe this is the striking thing
about all this reporting is that we've
been writing not only for politicians
but also for people for entrepreneurs
from the people within the ngo sector
and you would think that once you see
all those potential outcomes that they
would say we're here we want to be part
of the solution
but for some reason
everything relies on politics
entrepreneurs decide that they have this
wonderful initiative but they need the
support of the government
you would go to the academy to the
universities and it will happen the same
and until
we don't realize until we don't accept
that the entire society
must
convey
for a path for a mission
for
a development identity i don't know if
this is right but but
the people i mean
india knows
once
what their society
what kind of role the society wants to
play
california knows they're the innovation
center of the united states
china
made sure that he was the powerhouse of
the world
what puerto rico
would be what role puerto rico would
like to have
within the
us economy within the world economy
that's an answer that's a question that
remains an answer and unfortunately so
far i think that
not too many people
are willing to analyze it
and trace the course to achieve that
goal
thanks a lot thank you
i wanted to answer quickly uh
the we had for the first time i think we
had very two successful independent uh
candidates on the last election but both
of them had a very corporate oriented uh
campaign and their positions regarding
the debt were not really clear and they
were really like uh cautious like to
take a very
strict position about or repayment the
debt or having the public audit and
naming the debt illegitimate
uh what i think happened in the last
election is that we uh the government
that won
it's all it's always one of the same two
parties for the last 60 years but the
government that worked that one it is a
very conservative government it's a very
religious-based government uh the first
one of the first action of the governor
was to abolish gender perspective from
the i don't know what that means but
abolish gender perspective from the
public education system
and that's only one of the ways in which
he
tries to express the nature of the
government and in the context of a debt
crisis that's going to show in public
policies that keep criminalizing poverty
and having no
idea of what's really happening with the
most
precarious people in the in the island
for the next election i think that two
things are going to be very influential
first is the disillusionment with the
status of the island the
pro-commonwealth party
is having an internal crisis because
they are realizing that the commonwealth
is alive
at the same time the pro-statehood
supporters are still going through the
on
through the i can't believe this is
happening stage of having an unelected
federally imposed government
and realizing that we are going to be
left out of the health uh reform and
realizing that there's not going to be
any kind of federal support to puerto
rico not under obama not under the trump
administration and that that has been
like very shocking for the party of
carlo romero marcelo
and later we're going to have coffee and
we can talk about carlos romero marcelo
in detail and also the public audit one
of the big things about hedge clippers
that's why i mentioned carlos garcia
because some of the protests are moving
to the office of these people that's
connected to the debt crisis and the
role of starting to unveil those
responsible for taking uh
illegitimate death has been very
important and the resistance maybe can
be explained in the in the fact that
many of these people belong to both of
the main parties and have been for long
getting richer by the crisis so i think
that explains the resistance to the
public audit and also what could happen
in the next elections after the public
audit if it is ever completed yeah
thank you
i just want
to add briefly that
i think it's you know
necessary
to
analyze
how the different actors
uh
in puerto rico
uh place themselves
in this sort of drama
and
to try to understand the different
the positions of the political parties
and
personalities that are involved
but i think we should lose sight
of the structural dimensions
of the problem
there are structural dimensions
to the problem
that transcend
the political parties here and the
political parties in the u.s that's why
you see
the obama administration and the trump
administration basically adopting
similar positions regarding puerto rico
and it's not because
obama is such and such a trump business
and such is because of a structural
relationship between the us and puerto
rico
and
that is also true within puerto rico so
and one
aspect of the structural problems is
precisely their relationship that i try
to sort of
describe in my presentation and that has
to be addressed if that is not addressed
then
i think we will be
we won't be addressing the real problems
i am not saying that the status problem
is the only problem there are structural
economic
dimensions also and
and political also
structural political dimensions in terms
of how we have organized ourselves
politically internally and there are
many vices and many
deficiencies in our political culture
that have to be addressed so you know
you have to take into account all of
that so it's not just who is you know
president now or who is governor now
because we have been having these
problems four decades four decades in
fact for
for over a hundred years we've had
similar problems so and i think that's
where where the um
where some of the uh you know the hard
thinking has to has to be done and the
heart acting has has to has to be done
uh and in terms of the political
relationship but i think that
the
the colonial relationship as it is
is unworkable
i mean it's it's no matter who wins the
next elections it's unworkable
and
the other the other thing that you have
to we have to take into account is to
try to
distinguish i always try to do that
between
the structural relationship the basic
structural relationship between the us
and puerto rico and the particular
arrangement through which that
relationship expresses itself
the so-called commonwealth is just the
way that the colonial relation
relationship was organized after 1952
but
we might last into another
colonial articulation with a different
name
and so that's not the problem the
problem is the relationship itself
and and the deep uh
structural uh connections
which includes
by structure i also mean
i'd like
this notion of structure as
accumulated practice
the the the types of political and
economic practices and attitudes we have
developed over the decades
that explain why we are here
now and that might be the key
to
understanding how we can get out i'm
sorry get out
get out of the hobby of this of this of
this of these crisis because not joining
one crisis all of these crises
well please join me in applauding
[Applause]
thank you very very much for your
participation and um we do hope that you
join us in our second session
um
thank you
is
here
[Music]
[Music]
i'd like to welcome you to the
second round
of our
event in puerto rico an island under
siege
puerto rico's current financial
political and human rights crisis
so this is going to be the second round
table at which uh perhaps many of the
questions that were uh uh raised in the
first one uh may well be answered
we don't know maybe not we shall see um
i'd just like to i'm professor anibal
gonzalez
perez from the department of spanish and
portuguese so those of you who are not
from yale i'd like to welcome you to our
university and to the law school
and um uh just at the toad has a
parenthetical comment just a mere
impression um
and and uh since i'm in the presence of
professor stewart schwartz who has
written a wonderful book about
hurricanes in the caribbean and the
social history
it occurs to me that that
it
one possible way to uh or the many ways
to face this crisis is to think of it as
a kind of slow-moving hurricane
and uh because one of the issues that
that
is also floating around in the room is
the whole issue of
getting people together to actually
collaborate on some sort of solution to
a problem that affects everybody and so
certainly a hurricane would seem to
focus your mind a lot in that regard and
perhaps thinking about the crisis in
that way might help so certainly it's
it's an open political question
so without further ado i'd like to
introduce our speakers for this
afternoon
um our first speaker is going to be uh
jorge rodriguez
and
he is
director of the interdisciplinary degree
uh program at the universidad carlos
albiso
he's also the former dean of general
studies the general studies faculty in
the university of puerto rico
and he's also the founding president of
the puerto rican association of
international relations
our second speaker is going to be
danielle gutara
she is
danielle holds a phd in history from the
university of puerto rico
she is currently teaching in the
writing program at princeton university
and uh as i think we heard before she
will be a visiting fellow at harvard
university uh after the summer right
during the summer and uh last but not
least we'll be hearing
from jose rael alameda lozada
who professor alameda is a professor of
economics
in the university of puerto rico madia
west campus
he has served as a consultant in
economics and planning for the
government of puerto rico his research
deals with areas such as fiscal and
economic issues international trade
environmental studies and energy and
health economics in 2016 he served as a
member of the committee to audit puerto
rico's debt
so
we will begin our panel with professor
rodriguez peru's intervention
i wish to thank
yale university for this
invitation
and
for sponsoring
this
important
panel on this situation
in puerto rico
my
comments will try to place the present
situation in puerto rico
in a broad historical perspective
because with what we are dealing with in
puerto rico now
is not
a business cycle crisis
it is
i would call it without exaggerating an
ethical
change
a change in the way
the state is organized in which in the
way in which
puerto rico relates to the united
states so it's akin
to the changes that took place in the
1930s and in the 1940s
and i think we should approach
the situation in puerto rico not as a
fiscal crisis
but as a very
deep
institutional
transformation
and i have
called my paper promesa
an alice's predicament
and when i quote from alice in
wonderland
you will understand why i
put that title on my paper
i quote alice
would you tell me please which way i
ought to go from here
the cheshire cat
that depends a good deal on where you
want to go
alice i don't much care where
the cheshire cut then it doesn't much
matter which way you go
alice so long as i get somewhere
the cheshire cut oh you're sure to do
that
if you only walk long enough
i think
that
where analysis situation
that
we are walking
to some place we don't know
where
so
i would begin by saying that when you
read the fiscal plan
of february or 26th of this year
in the executive summary
it says
puerto rico's physical and economic
challenges are the result of an extended
period of fiscal
responsibility
ineffective leadership lack of long-term
economic planning
and frequent changes
and adds that puerto rico's current
crisis is the result of a failed
economic and political model
and there are other explanations that
have been given to the crisis
that place emphasis on the dominance of
a corrupt and self-serving political
class
and its use of this voice system to
remain in power
also others have blamed the bipartisan
system
that developed after 1968
as the cause for the present economic
malice
and i don't want to dispute those
explanations
they are the easy explanations the
obvious explanations
i would say that to understand what is
happening
one has to go beyond that
because i don't think the political
class in puerto rico is now more corrupt
than before
or that the political class in puerto
rico is more corrupt than the political
class in other countries
just look at brazil
for example
so
my thesis
in this paper
is that the what is happening now is the
end of an era for puerto rico's internal
institutional arrangements
and also in post-war u.s puerto rico
relations and it cannot be solely
explained in terms of the shortcomings
of it its political elite
its understanding requires to place it
in a broad historical
context
it is always difficult to define
historical periods
but i would say that what is
coming to an end now
is this institutional arrangement
the social economic political
arrangement
that began
developing in the 1930s and 1940s
and
consolidated in the 1950s
and then entered into crisis
i think the crisis really begins in
1973.
precisely when 936
came into
we were talking about that
in the 1930s
the response of the us to the crisis in
puerto rico
was to try to stimulate the economy
through a large bureaucracy
and federal funds
the bureaucracy was called preda and
then pra
and this
bureaucracy
became five times bigger than the
government of puerto rico
it generated 58 000 jobs
so the logic of the new deal in puerto
rico
was a kinesian logic
to try to stimulate the economy through
a bigger government and through
government expenditures
then
the second world war
also promoted
important changes in puerto rico
the war meant that
a lot of money flowed into puerto rico
for defense preparations
and also rom
revenues
came into the economy
and the salaries of the
soldiers there were over 50 000 puerto
ricans recruited in the second world war
the salaries also went into the economy
and while this was happening in the
economy
we had in puerto rico
rexford talked well as governor
and he was an institutionalist economist
who thought that the state had to be a
counter
balance
to private interests
and
talk was
a government governorship coincided with
the
reforms
pushed by the popular party in puerto
rico
so
by the end of the war there was a new
type of state in puerto rico with a new
type of economy
puerto rico was no longer a sugar island
it was a
modernized
economy
relying on industrial
investment
mainly foreign investment
the first phase of this
economic growth was
light
manufacturing capital
and that phase began to falter
and that's when 936 came in
to breathe new life
into that
arrangement
so i would summarize what i've been
saying but by
following
the interplay of the war context the
emergence of a reformist political force
that had asserted its unquestioned
dominance
by 1944
and the governorship of rex 4g toggle
created the conditions of the
institutional arrangements embodied
in the estado libra associated
of the 1950s
and the pattern of rapid economic growth
since the late
1940s and the early
1970s and i would say that thus that
arrangement also meant a certain type of
relationship with the united states
that although formally as
it has been argued
congress had plenary powers
it did not exercise the its powers
then as it is doing it now
that relationship
was based on strategic interests
during the second world war puerto rico
was a major military enclave for the
united states
and when the cold war came into being
very rapidly after the second world war
puerto rico was still strategically
important from the united states
and it was strategically important
and that began to change in the 1970s
but when the crisis of 1973 came about
puerto rico was still considered very
important strategically to united states
in the context of the cold war
so congress had a stake
in not permitting the destabilization
of the puerto rican economy
or social unrest
to
manifest itself and destabilize the
political arrangement
i think you understand more or less
where where i'm trying to get
by the 19 mid 60s there was a an
economist perhaps later you can
explain that
his name was genaro akero
and he was
also a functionary of puerto rican
government
and he pointed out in 1964 that the
puerto rican economic model
had basic flaws that were
showing themselves the basic flaws
was one that he relied too much on
foreign capital
and there was no sufficient role for the
puerto rican capital and two that the
public in debt
indebtedness
was rising very rapidly
so
since the 1960s
that was pointed out
still in 1966 six
the staten status commission
was very optimistic about the future of
the economy of puerto rico
the
economic report of the status commission
said
that unless
a status change would destabilize the
growth model of puerto rico the economy
would continue to flourish
it is ironic that it has not been status
change that has destabilized the economy
but world processes
that manifest themselves
in
the situation of puerto rico
so in the 1970s
if you uh recall what happened in 1970s
it was a very profound crisis of the
world economy
and of the u.s
economy
the background was the vietnam war
and the over commitment internationally
of the united states
the first thing that happened was that
nixon decided to
abandon the bretton woods a grain
agreement
the monetary agreement of the second
world war
and then
in 1973
the u.s economy that was growing at
seven percent rate dropped to two
percent
minus two percent
and then came the oil crisis
in 1973
as you know nixon supported israel in
the yom kippur war
and then the arab states established the
oil embargo
oil went from three dollars to 12
dollars
and what happened to the us economy was
felt in puerto rico like an earthquake
to the economy
uh
i'll just give you very briefly some of
the impacts that were felt in puerto
rico
a
1.3 billion dollars in value of the
production was lost in puerto rico
58 000 people lost their jobs
of these jobs that's 1973 and 1974. of
these jobs
38 000 jobs
were lost in construction
alone
they were unemployment rose to 20
there were 200
270
strikes and the
upr students went on strike for three
months
so we have a very similar
situation now
but what happened then uh what did
how did puerto rico get out of the
crisis
one
the rafale and the colon government
started taking debt
to increase the number of
government jobs
and government employment increased by
37 000
that was one anti-crisis measure
the other measures that happened had to
do with congress
and the u.s government government
food stamps were approved
in 1971 they were approved and there was
they were implemented in 1974
and very rapidly
money for food stamps rose to 500
million dollars
but not only food stamps also federal
funds began to rise
very rapidly
the other measure that congress took was
the 936
subsidy to industry
so
what congress did
and the
and the executive government
executive of the us government did in
that juncture
was to try to stimulate the puerto rican
economy for it to
overpass
this crisis
but what has happened now is in deep
contracts to what has happened in 1973
now in 1974.
what has changed
i think that what has changed is this
strategic relationship between puerto
rico and the united states
in the 1970s
still the u.s had a lot of military
bases in puerto rico it had roosevelt
roads it had vieques
it had rainy air force base
and now it has none
but not only
these bases were closed by
the willingness of the us to close them
but in the case of vieques the puerto
rican people
uh pressed to have the navy out
of vieques
and
the navy at least our friend juan manuel
garcia passalacqua
if he had been here he would have said
there's an invisible government in the
u.s
and that the navy was a very important
actor in that invisible government and
now the navy has no stake in puerto rico
at all
and
i would say there are very little
residual military
activities
in puerto rico
other people will be speaking about the
crisis
so i would only make some final
questions
one is what are the residual interests
of the united states in puerto rico
after the waning of a long-standing
strategic relationship
is there a real commitment with the
welfare of u.s citizens in puerto rico
is their concern that the with the
consequences
to the international image
of the us
of the economic collapse of its
caribbean territory
or does the united states doesn't mind
at all
seeing what is happening in puerto rico
if perhaps they think it has no cost
does the argument regarding respect for
the civil rights of puerto ricans
made by some political sectors have
resonance in u.s political circles
i would question
is there concern with massive migration
to the u.s or is migration being used
as a convenience skate bulb
that prevents confronting the problems
of a decaying economy
i previously thought that there was a
concern with the in the us with
migration
now now i doubt it
i think puerto rican migration if puerto
rico had had 40 million inhabitants
perhaps there was concern with migration
but the population of puerto rico is 3.5
million
and my puerto rican migration is like a
drop in the ocean
in such a huge economy as the u.s
and finally
has puerto rico falling through the
cracks of the u.s political system
alice
puerto rico will get somewhere
if it works long enough
the question is that we do not know
where
thank you
um so um just i would like to take a
moment to
even though already done so at the
beginning with my moderation to
express my profound gratitude to
professor maria hardan to professor
stuart schwartz to claise and to yale
law school thank you so much for this
opportunity
in 1963
clr james published the second edition
of his seminal text the black jacobins
to sun louverture and the san domingo
revolution
the most notable edition of the second
edition is an epilogue on the caribbean
that only dedicates one paragraph to
puerto rico
this brief mention argues that puerto
rico has the i quote near celestial
privilege of free entry into the united
states
the pan-africanist author also states
that i quote american money for
investment and american loans and gifts
should create the caribbean paradise
but concludes i quote puerto rico is
just another west indian island
this rationale is all too familiar
it has been insistently replicated as a
succinct afterthought of the case of
puerto rico
indeed the tourism industry in the
caribbean has consistently evoked
idyllic imagery of a
tropical paradise with pina coladas to
spare and to be enjoyed with the us
dollar
in the tribalized packaging of the
puerto rican experience the answer to
why puerto rico has now been able to
transform almost heavenly circumstances
into paradise
lies in the puerto rican people
this reasoning contends that there must
be an inherent flaw
of the people that impedes its political
and economic evolution into something
that closer resembles the bliss of
privilege
this rhetoric is fueled by the ambiguity
and the ambivalence that have nurtured a
veil of legitimacy
a veil that aims to conceal from public
discourse the racialist foundations of
the current political and economic
relationship between the united states
and puerto rico
in the book empire in world history
power and the politics of difference
jane
jane burbank and frederick cooper argue
that i quote the concept of empire
presumes that different peoples within
the polity will be governed differently
according to the volume empires are
sustained by the intrinsic element of
their politics of difference
politics of difference are imposed to a
premeditated racialization of colonial
hierarchies
empires of the 19th and 20th centuries
indeed benefited from racialized
differences since they justified
policies in terms of wealth distribution
and military recruitment
policy politics of difference were
fundamental not only for colonial
exploitation but for the international
projection of the progression of the
empire and its power
the authors point to the united states
as a peculiar example of imperialism
since even though its political history
was distinguished by a rapist rabbit and
bellicose acquisition of territories
the nation avoided the appreciation of
uh being an imperial power with colonies
nonetheless the united states had indeed
extended their power overseas at the end
of the 19th century and intervened in
the caribbean during
the 20th century before the invasion
of puerto rico as part of the
spanish-american war in 1898 the united
states had already nurtured economic
dependency in the spanish colony the
treaty of paris then ceded a spanish
province to the clause of manifest
destiny and a short lived military
government was inflicted until the
1900 forker act granted a civilian
government with its governor being
selected by the president of the united
states initiating a lengthy history of
political ambiguity of puerto rico as an
incorporated territory
the insular cases analyzed the
implications of the recently concocted
doctrine of incorporation to denote the
special relationship between the united
states and its territory a relationship
that could culminate at any moment by
the prerogative of metropolitan womb
in which congress would have the last
word and in which the supreme court
would assess the limited application of
the constitution through the ambiguous
slash ambivalent concept of fundamental
rights
the insular cases are still the
jurisprudence that sustains the colonial
condition of puerto rico and are
grounded on
racialist discourses and
plessy versus ferguson rhetoric
justice henry billings brown supported
the argument for non-incorporation of
puerto rico by in famously affirming the
following in the downs versus visual
case
it is obvious that the annexation of
outlying and distant possessions
great questions will arise from
differences of race
habits loss and customs of the people
and from differences of soil climate and
production which may require action on
the part of congress that would be quite
unnecessary in the annexation of
contiguous territory inhabited only by
the people of the same race or by
scattered bodies of native indians
the idiom foreign in a domestic sense
then encompasses the discursive
ambivalence that validates the
construction of inadequacy of puerto
ricans for self-government and in turn
disguises the role of racialism in
imperial intervention
precisely due to ideas of incompetence
during the early 20th century politics
of cultural assimilation were prescribed
by colonial authorities
like the imposition of english as the
language of public education
indoctrination of american heroes and
tales and the ban of puerto rican
nationalist symbols
the project of the americanization of
the puerto rican population was
constructed as benevolent imperialism
but fortunately its imper experiments
failed miserably as the colonial
population persisted in the defense of
the spanish language and the puerto
rican hybrid customs as unalterable
components of national identity
in 1917 the jones act was enforced
providing the puerto rican population
with united states citizenship the most
tangible repercussion of the jones act
would be the immediate immediate
eligibility for obligatory military
service in world war one
tens of thousands of puerto ricans
fought during world war one despite the
lack of voting representation in the
political arena of the united states
this statutory birthright citizenship
further unraveled the deconstruction of
the foreignness and non-foreignness of
puerto rico in the jurisprudence by
clarifying that the statutory nature of
this u.s citizenship was tied to the
non-domestic nature of the locality of
birth on the contrary the merchant
marine act of 1920 would hang on to the
domestic nature of puerto rico by
restraining its economic growth by
subjugating it to the interests of the
us domestic shipping industry
thus due to obscure fine print puerto
ricans were internationally pressured to
feel privileged about their second-class
citizenship and disadvantaged economic
structure
not surprisingly the first four decades
of the 20th century represented a time
of economic hardship and hunger
in puerto rico
the financial limitations of puerto rico
due to the cabot law the premeditated
deterioration of the coffee industry the
elevated levels of anemia the impact of
two destructive hurricanes and most
importantly the prioritization of the
interests of u.s corporations incited
the severe effects of the great
depression in the island
nevertheless during most of the 20th
century the metropolitan and colonial
governments would repeatedly concede
blame to overpopulation in puerto rico
in the location of culture omibaba
argues that power dynamics in
colonialism revolve around the concept
of mimicry this mimesis could be
described as an intentional cultural
assimilation that simultaneously
perpetuates an inescapable difference
in the case of puerto ricans one of the
marks of inadequacy would be the
signifier of poverty as an emblematic
trait not of colonial exploitation but
of cultural inferiority
furthermore puerto rican residents and
members of the diaspora were projected
as a dependent community for using the
stigma of poverty with a reputation for
welfare dependency
united states citizenship then
represents instead of a birthright a
burden
a crucial foundation of the
racialization of puerto ricans
definitions of race and ethnicity in the
united states have been distinguished by
hyphenated identities hyphenation
hyphenation embodies the linguistic
indicator of politics of difference
establishing a simplistic hierarchy of
americanness you impart to the
unintelligible political tensions with
the united states the puerto rican
diaspora has not been attributed nor has
it claimed a hyphenated identity
nevertheless the colonial politics of
difference and their implications with
the convenient racialization of puerto
ricans were manifest and discernible
during the debates that led to the
concretization of the foraker act the
insular cases the jones act and the
long-lived tensions surrounding colonial
relations furthermore 20th century
journalism a mass media in the united
states ascribed to an aggressive agenda
to racialize poverty and its arbitrary
collateral signifiers portraying
african-americans puerto ricans and
other minorities as inclined toward
criminal activity drug addiction low
academic performance and sexual
precociousness
the racialization of puerto ricans
evolved as one in which color did not
occupy a dominant position since the
racial category had to fit the diversity
of this mixed community according to
arbitrary 18 and 19
centuries so the scientific theories
that generated the modern constructions
of race diversity of color did not
represent an obstacle to establish
phenotypical traits with which to
recognize a distinct racialized other
particularly the celebration of puerto
rican culture the employment of spanish
the usage of two last names and most
importantly the accent that is connoted
in the racial slur that is used against
puerto ricans these attributes were
conceived as signifiers of indolence
ignorance and intrinsic violence making
it impossible for the united states
consciousness to envisage puerto ricans
as authentic american citizens
still the racialist currents of
geographical and bio biological
determinism induce the particular
racialization of puerto ricans
geographical determinism due an
inexorable connection between climates
and progress as evidenced in the downs
versus ritual
decision
typically depicting human groups of
hotter climates as lethargic and in
consequence retrograde meanwhile said
the scientific theories of biological
determinism conceived miscegenation as a
degenerative phenomenon
these racialist theories justified
colonial subordination of frozen in time
territories however obstrues the degree
of intuition interventionism could be
the role of ambiguity in racially
premised interventionism and its
repercussions in legitimacy and their of
legitimacy and thus in action
led to disconcerting narratives of
hunger marginalization of children
segregated military service and human
experimentation on human puerto rican
bodies that included interaction with
muster gas cancer cells
radiation and hormones
the justifications of both
interventionism and non-incorporation
centered on the racialized puerto rican
body as it is positive of imperial
concealment the bodily functions of the
puerto rican were to be observed
studied
supervised
in 1948 puerto rican landscape
landscapes were radically altered
because of the modernizing policy
policies of
operation bootstrap which originated the
transformation of the territory into an
island of cement by conceding investment
incentives to united states corporations
the facade of economic growth aimed to
hide again and again the question of the
agency of the colonized operation
bootstrap was yet another confirmation
that economic development would not be
produced or conceptualized by the puerto
rican people but instead u.s
corporations would become even more
dominant as 20th century colonial
relations highlighted discourses on the
modernization the education the cultural
assimilation of puerto ricans descent
and denunciations against the vague
minimization of colonialism
would be silenced with brutal force
it is in this juncture that the law 600
and the establishment of the
commonwealth of puerto rico would serve
as subterfuge to remove puerto rico from
the list of colonies of the united
nations when self-determination had not
materialized
the imprecise concept of the estado
libra associated puerto rico and the
approval by congress of a constitution
with questionable relevance did nothing
but hide under the rug the fact that
this
gesture has much more to do with
internal government than self-government
and everything to do with the projection
of the united states as a non-empire in
international conversations about
decolonization
still
the rest of the 20th century the united
states government turned a blind eye to
myths of puerto rican privilege and
dependency
even when the majority of puerto ricans
have consistently lived under the
poverty level
even when public trivializations of the
fiscal responsibility of puerto rico and
lack of federal income tax have ignored
the reality of second-class treatment of
puerto rico in u.s federal funding
even when the economic relationship
between the united states and puerto
rico has always primarily benefited u.s
revenue and constrained the economic
development in the island and even when
puerto rico has never had a political
voice or representation in the land of
the free and the home of the brave
the current political and economic
scenario not only only corroborates
sorry only corroborates that racially
fueled ambiguous ambiguous legislation
continues to be the law of the land in
which puerto ri the people of puerto
rico have incomprehensible standing
the discourse of colonial privilege
slash dependency is entirely too
convenient
therefore it is vital to analyze our
present-day juncture to find evidence of
near celestial privilege
as the 20th century has not provided us
with heavenly material
alas a three-headed monster has been
generated renewed uncertainty in puerto
rico
a monster that reminds us of the hibara
eating sugar factory in bagasso by
abelardo diaz alfaro
puerto rico versus frank franklin
california tax free trust represented
yet another confusing piece of
jurisprudence that claims that puerto
rico's estate for purpose of limitations
of bankruptcy law and it's not a state
for purposes of the protections provided
by bankruptcy law the census budget
decision
defeated the fiction of self-government
and self-determination by upholding that
congress and not the people of puerto
rico had been the ultimate source of
authority in the approval of the
constitution constitution of the esta
libra puerto rico
the last and most frightening head of
the monster is the oversight board
approved as an act distastefully labeled
by its initials as progressa promesa
sorry
the oversight board has been granted
with plenary powers of a democratically
selected government has the authority to
disallow the governor and the public
from participating in sessions and hold
the prerogative to review any proposed
legislation for
consistency
with the budget and fiscal plan
following the path of the unintelligible
promesa affirms that i quote nothing in
this act shall be interpreted to re
interpret it to restrict puerto rico's
right to determine its future political
status
and provides the oversight board with
the supremacy to approve a minimum wage
less than the federal minimum wage for
workers under the age of 25.
furthermore promesa requires the
government of puerto rico to i
co-designate a dedicated funding source
for the operations of the oversight
board while the oversight board
establishes the salary of the executive
director
controversially the recently selected
executive director of the oversight
board will be receiving an annual salary
of 625
thousand dollars adding to the millions
of dollars that have already been is
spent on highly publicized meetings
hence in addition to a billion dollar
debt the fiscal responsibility of the
middle class of puerto rico has been up
amended by the push to austerity by the
expenses of the oversight board and by
the recent imposition of a labor reform
by the conservative neoliberal governor
that has reduced both the income and
employment benefits of the already
burdened middle class of puerto rico
the oversight board then decided to
attack one of the most beloved
institutions in puerto rico
universidad de puerto rico by intending
to cut its budget by
450 million dollars
the university of puerto rico does not
only stand as the oldest institution of
higher education in puerto rico but it
also has been the embodiment of puerto
rican intellectual production cohesion
and opposition
the ulterior motives of promesa are then
evident this is not a conversation about
dollars this is an assault on one of the
increasingly scar space
spaces where puerto rican agency is
possible
however the representation of the
oversight board in u.s media is
apologetic and even hopeful for the
future of puerto rico under fiscal
supervision
the rationales behind the tolerant view
of promesa are the evidence that
oversight boards have been successful in
some states of the union and the
argument that the overwhelming debt of
puerto rico is due to inefficient local
governance during the last decades
this reasoning is also all too familiar
but amid a narrative of ambiguity and
ambivalence a few steps back also can
also engender a sense of certainty
there are enough unequivocal responses
to this reasoning by using the vague
language of our colonial history
puerto rico is not sovereign even though
it is fern
puerto rico is not a state even though
it can be spoken of in a domestic sense
therefore it could not matter less if an
oversight board has worked in a space in
which its population has political
representation and equal footing in the
law
the argument of incompetent governance
is entirely objectionable in the context
of the colonial history of puerto rico
because it perpetuates the racialist
discourses that insist that puerto
ricans do not have the capacity for
self-government are not worthy of
political representation and thus flaunt
the privilege to be supervised and under
perennial colonial subordination
promesa
epitomizes a significant blow to puerto
rican agency that cannot and will no
longer be dismissed by neither ambiguity
nor ambivalence
therefore the imposition of an oversight
board should not be scrutinized in
isolated conversations about
politics or economics
this is instead an overall a difficult
conversation about a painful narrative
of violations of human rights
even though it seems that the monster is
winning
the veil that legitimizes racially
premised interventionism is being ripped
to shreds
perhaps
the new celestial refers to this
purgatory in which we
the people of puerto rico are fighting
for the right to breathe
and to be let
alone
thank you
okay thank you
uh thank you very much i believe the
last
on the meeting so glad to mr
juarez gratu
maria
i'm very glad
to be here
representing puerto rico
and
the class of economists
i teach economics in the university of
puerto rico sometime
i i found a former prophet a student
from my classes
i i remember i used to go
with a lot of water a stand-up and a
glass of coffee
there is a way that we do the classes
and this is the way that i are going to
present my
presentation basically i will try to
emphasize in economic growth
because i think
that instead of had promesa
or instead of have fiscal bore we should
make a plan first of economic growth
increase the capacity of puerto rico to
pay
and then
to make all the adjustments to the
bondholders and so on but this is the
way
we are going to address my issue today i
want to also recognize that mr alfredo
gonzalez is a co-author he's a retired
professor of the economics
department in puerto rico
we have been dealt with that
area from a while
let's start with the main dilemma lemma
is a principle without economic growth
any level of debt services
will be unsustainable
and puerto rico will continue to endure
fiscal and economic crisis
that the way no other way forget about
the bad guy
of the movie promesa
fiscal boar and the seven
he needed the apocalypse
i'm going to say in spanish to be clear
we never solved the problem from my
point of view and the first
forecast in this
economic love forecast
usually they don't make any one
but
they ain't no way to solve the problem
of puerto rico using the way that they
are dealing with
a
promesa everybody know what we are
talking about they have basically is a
law and they have three main objectives
establish a physical website board
provide the process of restructuring the
debt
and make some procedures on critical
infrastructure projects
this is the structure of
promesa you have seven titles
title one and two is or the organization
deals with the organization of fiscal
board
in puerto rico
title three and six are very important
deals with the debts and credit and all
the litigation problems and puerto rico
and title three will be on the federal
court
and tartar phi
is is a general concern about some
issues with the economy
title four is the issue of rebelling
our infrastructure and the last one
seven is only a final word this is a
jingle bell jingle bell something like
that
they say nothing it's a it's a very
narrow
area
so
from my point of view right now we have
a big trouble in puerto rico a lot of
fight
the first fight
bondholders against boneholders
those general obligation bond holders
are fighting with the puerto rico sales
tax financial corporation bondholder
each one say you are illegal no you are
the one no are you only illegal no you
are the one
so they they are no way to address the
issue
edger funds they are fighting against
puerto rico the death of puerto rico and
also fighting to the government
bond holders also are fighting against
the fiscal board
and then they are fighting against
fiscal border because they certify
the fiscal plan from ricardo rossello in
2017 17.
so local legislature senate
and the house of representatives they
are fighting against the fiscal board
so instead of solve the problem we have
new problems right now
we are increasing we are new dimension
of the real problem
so
there is no other ways that go back roxy
titor 3 is waiting for us and maybe the
sosa
further a judge is waiting for us
to split the baccalaureate
[Laughter]
to split the catfish
physical board this is the way that i
teach the classes
there is no other way
the physical board they i i i heard
i saw that johannes are very presented
very similar
numbers but
according to them
you have to close the fiscal gap i
here's the problem
rising revenue
more taxes property taxes we had tested
already
but we have more taxes right now
even though
in the campaign
the claim of the
all the parties said hey you put a lot
of taxes
but now forget it the taxes are the same
one plus we have no another ones
so basically we have new taxes
on new way to enhance revenues and
according to the let me see
the the board we need 1.5 billion
that means 15 more on revenue
enhancements
meanwhile
in government rising we have right
sizing we have to
get down the government
by 1.5 which is 24
down of the current level
reducing healthcare spending is on 1
billion
this is because medicaid
efforts will maybe not be able
because congress will never
sign the bill to bring back
1.2 billions of revenue anyway we have
to look
1 billion to support the health
government program
otherwise we have no money
reducing high spend issues high
education spending university of puerto
rico as you said before
and pension reform also you have a cut
so then you have 0.5
billions of revenues
enhancement or savings
our forecast
we live forecast yes i am economist
we put together of this in the in our
economic economic models
and we look for it drop more or less of
5 percent
which is four times
the current annual decline of one point
three percent
then our main thesis is that federal
overboard
oversight board
and not properly diagnoses the islam of
the economy puerto rico
because we are not in a single recession
we are not in a single depression
we are in a even more deep concern
paradism which called strong economies
called secular stagnation
i will show you what is the meaning of
psychological nation
the boar has considered islam
according to this papers and so on that
i read
as a recession phase as a conventional
business cycle it's a drop in economic
activity we can fix it together we are
really impacted with the puerto rican i
love puerto rican oh my god
and all this stuff
and they are going to solve this problem
trying to furnish
the short-term liquidity to your fiscal
imbalance
and by restructuring
the debt
but
according to myself according to
author
the fiscal board and the expertise
members
has failed to current
diagnosis of the economy the economy our
economies is literal because our inputs
of production is less
and we have less capital human capital
we have less investment so the capacity
of growth is declining not because you
have a current business cycle it's
because you have a potential business
cycle you have a drop in the capacity of
growth
and you have to restore first the
capacity of growth create more revenue
create jobs and then pay the debt
not on the other way around
the same happens to the economics model
and so they have they look the
conventional business cycle
so basically
our main proposition
is that the fiscal board prescription
will hurt economic growth in the short
run and the middle run
neither it might restify
justify the structural failures of the
local economy
why
sorry i have absorbed throat
because they improper diagnoses the
problem
of puerto rico and all these measures
are really like draconics
a huge amount
its mitch rises uncertainty
about the impact on the long run
we we don't they never know about the
immigration they certify a plan in which
the
population decline was 0.2 percent
when the
history of puerto rico population is
declining by one person
so i don't know who did
this kind of
the decline in the population is 0.2
all the way down for 10 years
forget it it's not true because as long
as you make all this mess in the economy
you will hit you will see more
immigration to the united states
so that means that they
the variable immigration is endogenous
rather than exogenous as we call
later
so they they have no proper
rehabilitate programs because
the long run of the capacitor grows
so finally
fiscal board policy will probably return
economic growth
[ __ ] economic recovery and make the
subservice social distress and we're
going to get more inequality in the
economy of puerto rico so our main
conclusion here
is that from promesa
and from federal oversight board
the economy
will be first
worse off
rather than better off
the fiscal war will never solve the
problem
okay because maybe they close the bridge
between fiscal
gap
they close
revenue of course
they are increasing the taxes
they may decline their
the expenditure of course they are
declining the expenditure
so you close the gap in the painful way
to the citizen puerto rico
you close the gas using
the way
improperly manner in the proper manner
because you're going to reduce the what
economic welfare of the puerto ricans of
the resident
the way to restore the economic to close
the gap is to impose a sustainable
economic growth that will increase
revenue
and occur watch the politicals the
politician in puerto rico with the using
the revenue
and also to in decline the expenditure
in a good and manner in order to decline
the
expenditure
uh but increasing economic growth
in order
to close the gap not using
more taxes
decreasing revenue but encouraging
economic growth
and this is why i do
believe
the economy of puerto rico right now is
in secular technician
what is the meaning of that this as i
said before this is not a period in a
current recession this is not a period
in the current depression
we have let me show you some
graph here
in a conventional cycle you have to
frame
economic activity
you see here
this is the shoulder ambition
the structural framework
means being a social political
institution u.s relationship with puerto
rico colonial relationship and so on
in the conventional cycle
you economic activity fell
because you but you left intact the
framework
circular framework is in the same way
so basically you have a feedback of the
structural framework to reproduce
an economic activity
but
in a circular technician
you have a negative growth and
i need
because you have failures in this area
our structural framework
is in bad shape
so basically secular technicians
referred to a significant transformation
in the structural framework social and
cultural institution legal frame
technology demographic changes
relationships among countries including
the relationship with the united states
affecting the economic activity and then
the economic growth
so basically you have to restore
the new structural framework in a new
way this is the difficult way because
this is not an easy way to restructure
our structural framework so basically
the
some select feature of the secular
external nation
a decline in gmp potential
you have a high speculation in world
savings
you have a high debt output
ratio
you have lack of investment in the
economy
the lack of investment education and
infrastructure and slow down come in the
population growth and the composition of
the population
let's go to puerto rico and let's look
the symptom puerto rico have the same
thing low and negative economic growth
decline in potential growth
low capital investment high ratio of
public debt to national
gmp
a highest general survey for speculation
financialization they call
population decline and a net outflow of
migration let's see there some picture
remember iron economies i couldn't live
without
a couple of grass sorry
this is a comparison between different
recessions you see
the 1980s
which was
really
i don't this one
the 1990s recession which is very short
2000
this is the green one but this one
is our current recession
we overpass the threshold percent
decline
and over three months we have more than
ten hundred months in economic decline
this is the historical real gmp growth
of puerto rico from 1950 to to current
days
as you see in the 50 and the 60 puerto
rico grew
from 7 to 10
very strong growth after
a second war
here we have some
recession
but the economy is still
recovering
right now
you have a long
depression
a secular australian nation
and these are the forecasts of the
federal oversight board and including
the fiscal plane
i'm gonna make more
clear this
picture
according to
the current fiscal plan
for the year 2018 on 2019 the economy
will
be declining at four and three four
percent
we only recover
in a positive manner in two or twenty
five
i said before
of course
we have to take
i'm serious
that the forecast
they're gonna
they're gonna get
but it's here
okay
basically puerto rico is not
responding to the economy of the united
states you see
uh in this area
the line the blue line is the u.s rear
gdp growth and the
bar or in bar is puerto rico real growth
they move in tandem they move together
they have a high correlation of course
but right now
is on the way around the united states
is growing two three percent
but puerto rico is
go
down
the ratio on investment and fixed
capital is awful
you see in 1999
we have 30 percent of gmp
right now we have only 11.8 percent of
gmp the investment real investment
investment in machinery equipment
expanding the construction
you see we have before
a strong
recession but never compare with these
figures
the same happened to the real investment
you have low interest rate
prime rate is
fell down
but the economy
the investment
is no longer possibly sensitive
to that
decree in the
rate of interest
so
this is my
forecast
if we want to increase
as three percent
from a period of five years
we need to invest
119 billions
for that amount
we want to increase at five percent we
need to increase
or to invest
169.1 billions
during that period
the question is do we
do we have money
public investment i mean
public debt versus gmp
gmp is growing but public debt grew
rapidly and right now is one to one
previous one
before
206
the ratio was 66 percent
a death over the
gmp
so there is no way in puerto rico can
get rid of
all all of this mess
only with a boar
for a year in the only looking for
clothes they get between revenue
and
expenditure
the same happened to the
number establishment in puerto rico and
the thing happened to the employee
salaries is growing 1 billion down
puerto rico this is the second variable
very important this is the first time in
the history of puerto rico that we had
if
a
felt in the in the population in the
population of puerto rico
the population fell
400 000
sin 204
and this graph is really a migration to
the united states
the
the green line is the
population goes to united states to
puerto rico they
return
and the outflow migration
you see
the gap is
so what is i did this
calculation
uh immigration net migration
from 209 to all 15
has implied
economic losses
gmp
fell down by 3 billions
due to this migration process
means 0.43
of
gmp figure
income 2.8 billions
means 11.6 percent of the figures on
216. consumption meanwhile
and revenue collection has dropped us
so what else what are the policies that
we should
follow given that we have secular
stagnation
i have no answer
remember a young economist i have many
arguments and few
i try
to
make some
policies
let's go to
what they do international monetary
funds
the international monetary fund imposes
restriction but also provide technical
consultation and credit
to bridge the fiscal gap
a professor to australia who is a puerto
rican who teaches in
principle here
has said that they have a key pro quo
keep procurement i bring you you bring
me back
international marie pond imposes
financial restrictions to the stress
economy great
everybody knows that
second an overview protocol in
accordance between the
official of the monetary
international monetary funds and the
government
third provide technical assistance
and the last one
make arrangement
bring the to bring the sources of direct
and indirect right to bridge
the physical rehabilitation
we haven't had that from the us congress
we only have one part that's
responsibility
but never close the gap using some kind
of
a policy like that
of course
puerto rico
in a secular stagnation process
should promote small and medium-sized
projects to promote equal table
development and public investment
that being usually in puerto rico we
think i'm big
we
train a big project no no forget about
that we need small projects in the
community
to grew with this project
uh
instead of focus on growth
focus on
distribution of income
strategy you should be focused on the
economy facing the small rate of growth
we have to tolerate small rate of growth
one less than one
but increasing the net economic welfare
and the income distribution indicators
we have to change the focus instead of
huge problems
a huge
we have huge problems of course
huge project
and and my sugar is
going down
third to allocate funds from the
monatoria savings we have to look some
predatory savings we don't pay okay but
we have to use that funds
in order to finance some
high
value project of social benefit
maybe to certain perpetual funds from
financial social and physical
infrastructure projects
this all is another
to stop population decline by reverting
out migration
well technology
we don't need that all these people go
back to puerto rico especially in the
old physician physicians usually come
from puerto rico but they had connecting
puerto rico via sky and via technology
they are doing the business because i i
was talking about a friend of mine who
is from cabo rojo
padilla
who is right now in texas but he go back
to puerto rico two three times
per year
and they also they
they
have been
he has been consulting using skype
so due to the new technology you don't
have to institute
to bring your because this is a brain
drain
so knowledge can flow internationally
to accelerate investment in technology
advance and innovation direct to the
local establishment design measure to
reduce inequality aiming to increase
their labor share in the distribution
consisting by increasing productivity
and to spend aggregate demand
design and public investment program to
repair maintain and remodel the
former the infrastructure right now you
know you don't need to create more
infrastructure but we have had a lot of
infrastructure damage so try to remodel
try to re re-engineer
to assist a portion of funded public
debt restructuring to finance the above
financial investment program
this
this is a better this a very idealistic
way
we have a partner united states
i don't know is his apartment
let's try to believe
let's suppose that's
disappointing
let's try to
incorporate in alliance
to progress
just as the united states did in
previous years of course previous year
with the core war
we are not longer in that
so the partnership responsibility
entails an aid to fix the institutional
structural damage inflicted by the
economic growth process in puerto rico
they did
legal institutions mysterious exclusion
of puerto rico government proves
bankruptcy
so they this this is a partner so we
should go to
them and say hey you damage me
pay me
the u.s government should provide
equitable treatment to medicare and
medicaid benefit to people and haircare
provided to puerto rico due to this
alliance
so we have a lot of example of financial
sponsorship of the united states
to latin american countries
in 1989
reagan was the president ronald reagan
and they have a bad bone in the latin
american countries i remember quite well
the u.s treasury
imposed
a
brady brady was the
the chief executive of the u.s treasury
and they create a brady bond
a dollar denominated sponsor u.s
treasury
they don't have to bring money
they only change the rules
of the bonds
in 1995 the same happened
u.s organized a bailout to mexican
treasury
i remember the effect of tequila
tequila effect
so united states bailout
mexico
with 21 billions and they pay already
two years later
so there are many examples right now
ukrainian look
the
we have we have an executive summer and
a security executive
from ukrainia
the director
of the board how what is the salary
green
over
over um half million
six
yes but also they have expenses
they have to go
each
month to kiev
they live in kiev and we pay for that no
united states no the physical board with
the people of puerto rico vapor
these people will be covered
so
there is no way
so basically
they
occurred another possibility policy
is
the puerto rico economic development
department is taking advantage of modern
communication
they have been emphasized that should
establish a program to form a network or
exchange discovery from innovation among
puerto rican scientifics and artists
in outside puerto rico as a base for
domestic
project development
for example
the puerto rico sign and technology and
research trust
and the particularly its network program
puerto rico sign actively developed by a
prominent puerto rican doctor daniel
colon ramos associate professor in
neuroscience at yale university
so
we have to look connect
our
science and technology research with all
these myths
final
words in an ideal way of manner
thinking
as a puerto rican
we need a good neighborhood good will
aliens
as federer
roosevelt said in 1933
they have to look with respect
for rick
hopefully will be
that way thank you very much
there's a lot to think about
to ask about we have
i have a question for jorge
because you asked a question about what
are the residual interests of the us and
puerto rico
but i don't think you
gave an answer so do you have an answer
to that or listen
the thing is that the
to me i don't know if someone has any
other information
the us has no major military
and strategic interest left in puerto
rico
and also it sees no threat to its
security coming
from the caribbean because not even look
at what's happening in venezuela
is not even a
competitor
and in the case of cuba
the us and you are the best of enemies
now
and the
the
cruise ships go to havana
and that will continue this honeymoon
so there's no
a threat from latin america
in general
because
the
populist
governments are
having trouble to stay in power
so not even politically there's a
challenge in latin america
the u.s is looking
at
other regions
first it looked at
central europe
it put a lot of money in ukraine
so it's not that the congress doesn't
have money the u.s economy is growing
they put money where they feel they have
a strategic interest
for example they put a lot of money in
israel
so but they don't see that in the case
of puerto rico
i agree with
what alameda said
congress could do a lot
to
put puerto rico back back on the road to
growth
but what it could do costs money
and they don't want to spend money in
puerto rico that's what i feel
they haven't approved the bailout
they they are not approving more federal
funds
they
did not provide any substitute to
936
because perhaps 936 was not functioning
well
but it was something
perhaps it
uh
benefit more the corporations than
puerto rico
but it was an instrument for it was a
subsidy
for investment and the problem i think
what
alameda has underlined is
where will capital come from for
investment
it has to come either from
internal sources
from public capital or from private
capital
and
[Music]
unless there is some mechanism for
growth
the situation will continue but i don't
see
any mayor to answer your question
briefly
may your
strategic interests of the us in puerto
rico
might be for you and both
jose any residual economic interest for
example in the
retail industry
the creditors themselves
the market
puerto rico market are there any
significant residual economic interests
that the u.s would like to preserve
economic interest
well puerto rico right now is moving
from the manufacturing sector and to the
construction sector
to some areas for example aeronautics
i have done some studies for the area of
aguadilla
and they lose cancer models and the
cluster of aeronautic clusters has been
increasing and being improving in this
area
but only is a very
centralized in the area of agmadillia
what is growing the area of aguas is
growing because you have some cluster in
this area so let's try to make
in this way
also you have cluster maybe in the
health cluster
maya west for example for example they
you have some clustering increasing the
the number of physicians around
specialists and also you have a lot of
clinics educational background also
clustering maya west uh that we have
only the university of puerto rico the
catholic the university
we have also
until college
from the alventica
there's a religious sector and we have
people from costa rica studying in that
university from cuba we have also people
so maybe puerto rico has to decentralize
the economic growth in into areas
as i said before
i never row down here but
gonzalez and myself we have been doing
some research about what we should do in
the economic development process
but we need capital
uh
also puerto rico in the maritime field
has lot
has
lost many opportunities
exploiting the maritime routes
and what has happened with roosevelt
roads naval station
is very good
because there was an infrastructure
there
uh which would have been available for
economic development of puerto rico and
it has been completely abandoned
and lost there were many millions of
dollars invested in that base
in a it has an airport it has roads it
has
a very important
bay for a port
so i i don't doubt that there are
potential
areas for growth in puerto rico
yes thank you thank you for your
presentations and the previous panel as
well was very stimulating
i would like to
consider the paradigm shift that
professor rodriguez
suggests
and think of aspects that we i don't
think we discussed enough
the situation of puerto rico
uh
geopolitically not exclusively in
relation to the to the united states its
laws
and it and its economics but rather
puerto rico in a different type of
context
where it looks more towards latin
america or more towards spain
and where politically
it claims a certain identity that is not
subjected to u.s laws
i wonder and i would love to have jorge
wanna here to think of uh the impact
that the diaspora will have
in this type of
legal configuration but also a certain
juridical identity for not only the
people of puerto rico but puerto ricans
not exclusively cited in the islands so
when we think of the lack of political
representation
in congress we can think of
that puerto ricans do have political
representation in congress
just not
puerto ricans elected by the people of
puerto rico in puerto rico or
the
the representation we have within
certain legal
circles like the fact that there is a
puerto rican in the supreme court to the
united states
so
in that regard can we think of a future
where this type of
transnational situation with massive
representation in the united states
may have an impact
so that puerto rico will have some sort
of standing equal standing
like
as if it were a nation with a certain
degree of sovereignty
beyond its just
simple colonial status is that possible
also thinking of economic growth
uh will remittances
so puerto rico acts as a colony of the
united states we don't necessarily think
of remittances but if
we consider puerto rico
a sovereign nation
then we could see an economic growth
connected to remittances from the
mainland as if it were a different
nation i don't know if that
rings a bell or incites
some
i think that
the relationship with the diaspora has
been
completely neglected puerto rico
has given
no importance
if you look at dominican republic
the dominicans
have american citizenship
dominican citizenship and they vote in
the elections for the dominican republic
but that is a constitutionally
an abomination when you're discussing in
puerto rico that puerto ricans in the
united states could elect
a representatives to the puerto rican
legislature why not that's what they
have done in the dominican republic to
connect the diaspora to dominican
republic
so definitely i agree with you that
would be a very important
point how how to develop that
relationship
and you mentioned it
it could be a tremendous economic
asset to puerto rico and also you
mentioned
spain
and mexico both countries have important
investments in puerto rico
brazil could have been a future partner
for puerto rico but the brazilian
economy is in chambers
and also puerto rico must look at china
china is investing a lot of money in the
latin america and the caribbean
and that
relationship with china has to
develop
with russia is going to be more
difficult
but with china apparently
trump took him to his house in florida
so she brings uh
turn off the radio please
the president of ecuador was here last
year okay and uh he told me that there
are now four representatives in the
ecuadorean congress that are elected by
ex-patriots by
ignorance who live with it i live
externally they just have the elections
if you mention that in puerto rico
the puerto rican political elite doesn't
accept
any participation of puerto ricans in
puerto rico
they they say they should not go to
plebiscites they should not vote in the
government
and that is a very short-sighted view of
immigration
community in the u.s usually
politicians in puerto rico they believe
that the use of the problem by the
statehood or by independence or by free
association
this is not true
this is the way
they think and it's very difficult to
get rid of a deep mind in puerto rico
because everybody followed
the leader
many well everybody know many people
follow the leaders
thank you
kind of double-headed question
for
um
clearly there are limitations in our
status condition
as
this
monstrosity that is the the
and as very well dr frederiquez would
have quoted from alice in wonderland we
won't go anywhere unless we move
we will go somewhere we move
what
does dr alabada as an economist think
that
the best economic option for puerto
rico's satoshis more independence
and looking to partners outside of the
united states
getting more sovereignty more ability
more flexibility through a treaty of
free association with the united states
while claiming our sovereignty full
annexation and my other question more
more on the economic side
with the flaws of um
the
event the capital the defendant
capitalism
should we try and revive that or should
we try and
fix its flaws starting with the
uh
substitutable industries uh on the
island itself and try and
rebuild something better from the ashes
well the question is very exciting
because i will never be objective we
never be
i've i support a free state association
you know i believe that stay good it's
not for us
we are a nation
we we we basically are different from
the united states different culture
uh we are not the united
states we are in the united states
because they want
italian associated is an instrument that
they create for themselves
so that is very difficult to
understand
is the united states going to bring the
statehood to puerto rico when
puerto ricans broke
puerto rico is broke because the main
political parties of puerto rico
supported the united states populare and
pelepe
those supporting
their relationship with the united
states
are
those who broke puerto rico
and because puerto rico is also a
corruption they have a lot of corruption
between all these two parties
then basically
many of the people in puerto rico only
20 percent speak fluently english
including myself who speaks english only
i was there in some place in 30 years
ago but i don't speak english fluently
so
it's very difficult to realize that the
united states will someday
bring into the state
puerto rico this is my concert
do you support sahil
i i would say that
i would recommend that you read the
economic report of the status commission
of 1966
that people have forgotten about that
and this
that economic report said that in 25
years
puerto rico
could be
admitted as a state if it maintained the
same rate of growth that states of the
united states
that's what the report said
and that was 50 years ago
and the rate of growth of puerto rico is
negative
so i wonder who's going to accept puerto
rico's tape
it's very difficult to imagine
and also as
he showed it
the perspective for the next 10 years
are of a downslide in the economy
because the
fiscal board has said
that for things to get better they must
get worse
you know
and we are in wonderland
because what political system can endure
that tells the people that they need to
spend 10 years in a crisis
before there is growth again it's the
situation of puerto rico is very
complicated because they are doing the
thing in their way in this
yeah because they first they had to look
economic growth sustainable economic
growth and then to try to fix
revenue and close the gap and boy but
the discussion in the last years and i
don't know if you would agree has been
about the fiscal crisis
there has been very this little
discussion about
economic strategy
and economic development
that is not discussed
and i am not economist but i would like
to know how is growth going to
be
developed in puerto rico again on what
can an economy be based
be it independent or state
because
if puerto rico becomes a state
it will have to pay federal taxes
with what will it pay federal taxes
it needs to have
some wealth
for it to
pay federal taxes
and
what the fiscal plan says
is that the government of puerto rico is
going to be shrunk
they say it's right-sizing
but in fact it's downsizing
radically
the size of the government of puerto
rico
but
how will growth happen
that's what i don't see this cause the
center of new economy is working on a
plant a tragic plant
they hire a stick list just strictly and
also catalan is working
with then bobonis germa bobonis
uh they are i don't know what happened
no no no
they are independent
cyclical policies that the the oversight
court is in is imposing which have
nothing to do with economic growth they
don't care about a number this is like a
fire stand
and you mentioned the negotiator the
role the imf is true that the imf when
it signs conditionality agreements with
countries it provides resources to help
them close the fiscal gap on the other
hand those agreements are a product of a
negotiation between an international
financial institution and a sovereign
government
is this is though the imf has gone in
and taken over the government of the
country and is just taking out what it
needs it's always a tension between the
imf and cyber governments that imf wants
to get the resources back to the you
know wants to pay the debt and the
country wants to grow and
and what comes out of those agreements
is a kind of negative it's a product of
bargaining and this is the situation is
completely perverse in this way
there's i thought there was a disconnect
in your presentation because it was very
persuasive that the only real way to
solve the problem is to reinstitute
economic growth
but then when you got the prescriptions
it sort of became we're going to have to
put up with you know some some very very
low level of growth which i think is
realistic but it doesn't seem like it
seems as though the real
way to be thinking about this is first
of all get out of this terrible
political straitjacket which the united
states has
persuaded become also so depressed by
the case analysis that there's the
united states doesn't have any interest
you know it's just a fire sale that's
all it is right now
and you know once that can be solved god
knows how that's going to happen then
you're looking at the other parts of the
world as sources of capital and as
traditional
partners so that's how latin america has
gotten us right
in argentina
for good now obviously that's mostly
commodities and it doesn't seem it seems
like this island of concrete may be well
positioned to become a commodity
exporter but
yeah
it seems like
you're you're completely right that it's
this is not
there's no solution to the actual
economic problems of the island it's
just a fire sale
that's the way they're treating it
okay okay
i was wondering along the lines of the
question that was asked earlier about
the
diaspora if there have been any economic
analysis of
how much the puerto ricans that have
moved to puerto rico are contributing
to the us and if if that could be used
as a political argument
to argue maybe something like i'm
wondering like the us must have
benefited
economically from the huge
immigration of puerto ricans if you were
to calculate how much the federal
government is receiving annually in
taxes
by that by that immigration that they
have gotten and if could you make a
political argument
that would be more valuable about
decreasing that amount back in puerto
rico because i i'm just i'm surprised by
because the conversations yeah the
conversations are many times sound like
like i mean the framing the framing is
the right framing and it's actually very
the forecast is very negative
but the the
those graphs that show the puerto rican
decrease
you know they're not they're people that
are not like jumping into the ocean and
drowning
they're like they're coming here 40
minutes apart
and and
leverage in some way you mean that
is that right exactly so the exactly
that so that that
so what is the economic impact of that
of that net increase that you're showing
there
and can that be leveraged in some way
like when we talk about leveraging we
usually talk politically but
economically can it can an argument be
made
they have made this type of argument
uh usually in puerto rico i
the sponsor i i
have been consulting by many group that
came here to puerto rico and we use the
same
the same frame the same arguments that
hey listen congress you receive puerto
rican and they bring you back
salaries and they are contributing your
their physician their scientifics here
but
they don't bother
yes they don't have nothing happen
they they receive the information okay
oh great right puerto rican
oh my god
very cute but nothing happened
including concluded that many puerto
ricans have been served in the military
in vietnam
in
in afghanistan iraq
they are using that
frame words they are using that word
nothing happens
i ask for a
couple of things one is
victoria was just saying a lot of the
people who are going back to puerto
ricans that are going back to puerto
rico they're going there to retire
right i mean it's not like they're going
there to advance to
set up you know factories whatever
but the other is um
i haven't heard too many people talk
about the rich anglos that are being
drawn into the into into puerto rico
i'm thinking you know there is it's not
just that puerto rican
are outflowing but they're replacing the
population
so what can you say about that with all
these rich um
condos you know multi-billionaire
multi-million dollar condos and so forth
and attracting anglos to come in
and
essentially do what santana did
with
the u.s when they came into tejas and so
forth is to say you know you swear
allegiance to the u.s flag well here's
you know you're going to be a resident
of puerto rico what do you talk about
because that to me is just as important
as the other stuff that's going on
as far as i know in terms of
there is not a big
flow of anglos to puerto rico
what the puerto rican government has
tried to do is to
attract millionaires right
and some millionaires are going to
puerto rico because they they have a tax
treat very
low tax exemption you know and they're
what i i doubt that that it as a
strategy of economic development
you don't get economic development by
attracting a few millions
but there's no substitution of
population because
there's no
let's say puerto rico
were growing
and there was a lot of wealth creation
it would attract a lot of
migrants
but that is not happening in fact
dominican
immigration to puerto rico has
abused so the ones that are going back
to puerto rico are puerto ricans
not
[Music]
not as many as are living
i don't have the exact figures but i i
think there are about twenty thousand no
that come back every year
coming back to puerto rico coming back
well more or less
you have yeah that goes this is one one
year
25 hundred thousand
but
for ten years maybe
if i may if i may dovetail some of these
discussions
it is interesting it may not be a
massive pattern but it is interesting to
see
many young people returning to puerto
rico
and you have certain enclaves that
become
let's say some sort of cultural
remittance
of a certain or a certain
manifestation of a certain indie let's
say culture of the united states in
puerto rico like in the santorus
in the early 20th 21st century
2002
there was a new eureka manifesto
to which i i think people like arne
quintero signed on
and it had the intention of creating a
swath of land
that connected the old san juan with
santorse
to create some sort of corridor of
culture of new energy and and there were
many young people and something has
happened and something massive happens
the bookshop
and there's cultural activity in that
area of santorini
included you receive a lot of basketball
players dalmau netali garcia and many of
them that are there
now placing in puerto rico and they live
in puerto rico not actually but they
they are in california but almao and his
sons
also live in puerto rico
so they stay there so there is that type
of exchange that is impacted by the
diaspora and in addition to that there
is massive political representation not
only in congress but also in state
capitals like in hartford connecticut
for a long while there was a puerto
rican
mayor there are council people
which act as political representatives
and this i am borrowing from an argument
by eduard melendez and a certain center
for puerto rican studies that has been
actively studying this type of
relationship
so i i just want to add that to the
description i'm afraid that in order to
solve this problem
the united states have to do something
if they want to incorporate us as a
seahood as a state of the united states
go ahead
but they are not doing doing nothing is
what i'm doing is
a current physical board that
do not solve anything
i don't know
i'm getting crazy
no just very briefly uh to
his point over there in regards to you
know the anglos or what have you it
might it might not be
i mean
i would agree with your point it might
not be perhaps in terms of population of
substitution of the population but what
you are having is the taking of a space
right because you have pulse and buying
all these empty lots and stuff and
condolences
and whatnot so as people are getting as
we saw in the presentations and the
first panels as people are losing their
homes and losing their property and such
uh you got all these multi-millionaires
that are coming in by way of these laws
that are buying up these prime real
estate
and the other thing very briefly that i
wanted to say in regards to the diaspora
island island relations and such in
regards to the political aspect and
political
puerto rican politicians on the mainland
uh and in the relationship with the
island you know it is is a little bit a
little problematic because i'm thinking
you know there's always a thing that of
the main politicians you know like
hillary and obama and the such and they
come in their in their campaigns and
they come to puerto rico and they stay
for six hours and they they get their
money there's something similar i mean i
don't wanna it's a somewhat unjust
comparison but something similar happens
with with certain
uh prominent uh puerto rican uh
politicians on the mainland in their
relationships when they come to the
island they might be might not be
looking for money but
menis
and such and
such and they come for a type of
cultural
validation and they participate in
anti-junta or anti-promesa things but
then they back up people that back of
the you know
so it's you know it's it's complicated
i just wanted to make a good comment
because the diaspora is is uh i think
that
when we talk about puerto rico's
recovery
the gas problems be part of the equation
there's no there's no question about it
and there there are a couple of things
happening there is an organization that
is saying it's compromise
and what they're doing is precisely
gathering creating these huge networks
of puerto rican professionals throughout
the mainland um
in order not necessarily only to bring
and discuss social and cultural issues
but also
from the business side from from
professional connections um and that's
that's that's i would say that it's
it's it's good
and another thing is that of course the
economy is going and performing badly
but there are people that in fact
they're having at last in puerto rico
some because they're making a lot of
money because of the crisis
but there are other other people that
despite the crisis
decided to
to move forward
for example we have now companies that
are incredibly successful and they
wouldn't dare to export until they were
faced with the situation that their
native market that puerto rico market
couldn't bear any more revenues to the
to the companies so now we have
companies exporting
the brazil
to
the middle east i i've known an
architect that is providing services
architecture and engineering services to
the middle east to the government to one
of the governments over there um
and these companies are performing
really well they're there they want to
remain and keep their operations there
and what they're doing is that they're
looking for other puerto ricans so they
can just go ahead and try to
promote those companies
and and in that sense
i i think that that's part of the
solution you know i i know that maybe we
could be too pessimistic but that's
that's that's also something about the
mission
uh i wanted to just comment something
about the agency that danielle actually
uh emphasized in her presentation
and and i think maybe it's in a positive
note there's some
positive
i would say
examples of this movement that many of
the cases actually you mentioned and
ariana too in her presentation and also
we wanted to mention the new political
alliances that are
the
i think there's some uh
fragmentation of the homogeneity of the
political traditional political parties
in puerto rico at least that's my
perception
and also the important uh political
activists in the environmental area that
are really responding to this
effort to sell
many of the good lands that we have in
puerto rico including
and um and many of the lands that are
even
part of the of the feather road
natural
so you know that they're protected and
they are responding to that so you know
i think that it's it's also going to be
because we can't what what
i think that is important to recognize
in this scenario is that one of the
proposals can be to sell some things but
what are you going to sell and in what
conditions and who's going to be
affected by that
so i think it's something that you have
to take to think about and uh i want to
thank all of you for coming i want to
thank our speakers i want to thank the
organizers
[Applause]
you